Ok
Ich bin wieder da
Es war eine gute Idee, Chatge heute morgen
dass jemand gesagt hat
dass die Preview-Version für 23h2 raus ist
Wollen wir uns das ganze noch mal angucken. Ich hoffe, die ist auch wirklich raus, sonst wurden wir jebaited
You got jebaited
Müssen wir mal schauen
Jetzt muss ich aber erst mal ISO runter, wobei, ha, schon das erste Problem
Schon das erste Problem ist es die Frage, gibt es davon überhaupt eine ISO?
Ich lecke eindeutig critical information
23h2 ISO, gibt es denn sowas überhaupt bei Microsoft?
Plus ISO-Download, ja, sag mir
Wait a minute, das ist doch, das ist doch jebait, oder?
Das ist doch
Ja klar, ja klar, da, ganz bestimmt kriege ich da das ISO
Findet ihr nicht auch, dass es nach einer offiziellen Microsoft-ISO-Download-Seite aussieht, wo ich da rauskomme? Doch, doch, eindeutig, auf official ISO
Official, official, Leute, official, pass mal auf official, lass uns mal gucken, wie official das ist, ach hier, guck mal
Official ISO, auf dieser super official Seite, okay, Moment, der Sache muss ich jetzt nachgehen, was, wo kommt man da raus
Wenn man das downloaden will
Wait, das probieren wir jetzt aus, das probieren wir jetzt aus, wobei, ich bin nicht sicher bin, ob ich das aufmachen soll im Stream, wer weiß, was für Seiten man da rauskommt
Aber wir riskieren das einfach mal, im Zweifelsfall, im Zweifelsfall muss ich einfach Wort und alles instant, instant löschen
ISO-Download, official, okay, okay, official Microsoft-Seite
text
YouTube, official, official, okay, how to download ISO-File
Achso
Dass wir auf die Insider-Preview-Seite gehen müssen, ich glaube, da wäre ich auch noch draufgekommen
Page loading
To access this page, ach, na, jetzt kommt dieser Shit wieder, nein
Nein, nein, nicht wieder Microsoft-Kack-Account anlegen
Ich hasse es, Alter, ich hasse es
Warum macht es einem Microsoft immer so schwer?
Es waren überhaupt noch Zeiten, wo man sich den Kram ohne Account
Irgendwo runterladen konnte
Ich muss mal kurz was trinken, übelst durch, seit heute Morgen, seit ich heute Morgen gerannt bin und wieder einen Liter rausgeschwitzt hab
Hab ich den ganzen Tag, bin ich übelst am Trinken, ich hab wahrscheinlich schon gefühlt das Fünffache reingeschüttet, was heute Morgen raus war
Lasst euch übrigens von dieser
Von diesem Vorschau-Text hier oben nicht, es ist kein XXX-Bild oder so, auch wenn das 6 drinnen vorkommt in der Shortner-Uhrl
Reiner, reiner Zufall
Aber warum ist denn der Sound, übrigens, warum ist denn der Sound aus?
Ah, weil wir nicht die ganze Zeit immer das Gleiche im Hintergrund laufen haben wollen
Komm, wir machen ein bisschen Wuppwuppwupp an, Wuppwuppwupp ist immer, geht immer. Okay, 10-Minute-Mail, let's go
Exakt die hier brauchen wir jetzt
Wie macht man denn?
Sign-in, okay
Das machen wir doch
Aber, komm, komm, wir machen das, wir machen so was Neues. Safe-Logins, nee, nee, Moment, hab ich da?
Admin, ja, geil, geil, Fake-Dinger
Fake-Dinger, Fake, Fake sein, okay
Register, create one
Moin, Yantari
Create new account, ja, besser
Use the phone number instead, nee, nee, nee, nee, alles schon gut, alles gut
Hoffentlich darf ich. Nein, ich nehme bestimmt nicht das Random-Passwort hier
Wir müssen jetzt erst mal kurz, dass ich nichts leake, was habe ich da für komische TikTok-Videos, will es gar nicht wissen, irgendwas, was mir der Chat, der Chat geempfohlen hat, glaube ich
So, toggle clipboard off, so, und jetzt muss ich mir ein Random-Passwort mal ausdenken
Bestes, bestes Random-Passwort ever, was ich mir ausgedacht habe, gucken, dass Groß- und Kleinschreibung dabei ist
Passwort, bam
What's your name? Wup, kek
Hier, ganz normaler Name
Wer kennt, wer kennt Wupkek nicht?
Wir sind auf jeden Fall volljährig
Sonst mag das Microsoft wahrscheinlich, Germany
Verify E-Mail, easy, reise neu dran
Boah, das ging ja hyperschnell
Das ging ja ultraschnell jetzt mit der E-Mail
Verify E-Mail, easy, reise neu dran
Pass auf, das ist jetzt irgendeine Phishing-Attacke vom Chat, Chatgehacker-Man am Start, gibt's zu
Wer ist es gewesen? Das war viel zu schnell für eine normale E-Mail
Yes, ich will unbedingt, ich bin ganz scharf drauf, Microsoft Information und sowas zu bekommen
Create account, solve this puzzle
Äh, äh, ich verstehe das Puzzle nicht
Ich verstehe das Puzzle nicht, was muss ich machen?
Ach, auf next drücken, ach so, okay
Alter, Captchas ist mittlerweile nichts unter 300 IQ mehr möglich, das überhaupt zu lösen
Okay, jetzt muss ich, das sieht auch ein bisschen unanständig aus, oder?
Use the arrow to rotate the animal to face the direction of the hand
Okay, was?
That was not quite right
Wie jetzt? Try again
Ach so, ach so ist das gedacht, okay
Ja, ist es jetzt so oder so? Ich hoffe mal so
Boah, nochmal, oi oi oi, haben wir Glück gehabt, close call
Was das ist? Unerkundliche Captcha Ideen
Verification complete, das ist ja sehr nice
Okay, you need to be a member of the Windows Insider Program
Wie dingse ich mich zum Windows Insider Program?
Inside Windows, Gatschibass
Ich versuche mir gerade ein Microsoft Account zu machen
Und mich zum Windows Insider Programm anzumelden
Wie, wie, wie, wie, alter, wie viel Gelaber ist denn hier auf der Seite, please?
Ich will ein Windows Insider werden, Microsoft lasst mich doch
Ich bin ganz scharf drauf, lasst mich Windows Insider werden
Register, sign in, jawoll
Ich bin, ich hab mich doch gerade sign in
Ein Insider, Leute
Insider, Leute
Wir sind, wir sind Insider
Richtig privilegierte Insider, ja
Warum ist alles, was mit Microsoft und Registrierung zusammenhängt, so ultra beschissen?
Question
Warum passiert nichts?
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich irgendwas aus Versehen geblockt habe
Wir machen das nochmal mit Blocker aus
Okay, nice
Das gibt's nicht
Okay, was ist das für eine Kacke, warum geht das schon wieder nicht?
Ich will mich registrieren für das Insider Programm, jawoll, ahja, okay
Ich accepte die agreements, beste
Ich fliege
Perfekt, wir sind Microsoft Insider, exzellent
Windows Insider Preview, ISO, ja, pow
Select Edition
Insider, okay, jetzt
Bin ich mir etwas unschlüssig
Also wahrscheinlich brauchen wir das höchste
Bild, also wahrscheinlich das
Es gibt Dev, Beta und Canary
Canary hat das höchste, hat die höchste Bildnummer, also sollten wir wahrscheinlich das nehmen, oder?
E-Mail läuft in 3 Minuten aus, MonkaS, ich brauche noch 10 Minuten länger
Nee, eigentlich brauche ich die E-Mail überhaupt nicht
Oh, Confirm Account Marketing Preference, leck mich
Confirm
Select Product Language
Englisch
International
Kona
Okay
Ha!
Oh, habe ich überhaupt genug? Ja doch, ich habe genug, Disk Space
Das ging ja gerade nochmal gut hier
So, bei der Gelegenheit, haben wir noch eine VM für Windows 11?
Nein, haben wir nicht
Dann müssen wir gleich eine VM für Windows 11 anlegen, weil eine Windows 11 VM ist natürlich nicht so einfach, wie man sich das vorstellt
VM, Klick, Klick, weiter
Nein, nein, nein, man muss Secure Boot und TPM und den ganzen, ganzen Geschäft einschalten, dass das funktioniert
Seit wann benutzt du Firefox unter Linux schon immer?
Ich benutze unter Linux so gut wie nichts anderes als Firefox
Und zum Testen von Webseiten noch zusätzlich Chrome
Also das meiste, was wir an Frontend-Sachen machen, ist mit einem Chrome-Vorschaubild
Aber zum normalen Surfen und sonst wie rumgucken, bei Linux ist immer Firefox
Und unter Windows ist es eigentlich nahezu immer Chromium mit etwas Chrome und manchmal etwas Firefox
Und was ist Firestorm?
Ich will es gar nicht, ach du, das ist dieses Gigabyte-Tool, wo ich gar nicht weiß, wie kommt das überhaupt drauf?
So, dann lasst uns doch schon mal
Was gibt's Neues in 23h2?
Also, es gibt unter anderem Neues, dass man, habe ich zumindest gelesen, dass man in der Task-Leiste die Sachen wieder entgruppieren kann
Müssen wir mal ausprobieren
Wir haben heute Morgen, witzigerweise, ein PC-Welt-Artikel zugeschickt bekommen
Warum auch immer PC-Welt, aber da stand drinnen, was es Neues gibt
Da stand unter anderem drinnen, kann man das closen, dass ist jetzt
7-Zip unterstützt und allerwichtigste
Aufheben der Gruppierung von Task-Leisten-Apps und einblenden von Labels mit einem Klick
Ob das mit einem Klick ist oder zehn, das interessiert mich persönlich überhaupt nicht, Hauptsache es geht
Kennst du schon den Trick, dass beim Setup mit der Region Englisch keine Plot-Ware ins Startmenü landet?
Nö, kenn ich nicht, also kein Disney+, Netflix und Geschiss
Erlegen wir doch mal eine neue VR-Maschine, wie viel Platz haben wir noch? Davon hängt es ab, wo wir das Ganze anlegen
Wir haben genug, ich meine, wir brauchen 80G oder so und danach fliegt es wieder weg, das sollte kein Problem sein
Machen wir mal Typical, wobei ich ja eigentlich immer manuell mache
Ah, mit Typical richtet das vielleicht schon richtig ein, Windows 11
Jawoll, ganz toll
Was ist das? Achso, ja, TPM-Encryption, pass auf, Top-Secret, kommt hier nie drauf
Ihr werdet nicht erraten
Ihr werdet nicht erraten, wie mein Passwort ist, das ist zwar nicht secure genug, okay
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9
64Gig ist auch okay, Multiple File sollte mir auch recht sein
Das Einzige, was wir machen, ist, wir machen den Printer raus bei der Soundkarte
Ja, lassen wir das dran und das ist zu wenig
Das Ding braucht mindestens, das braucht 4 Cores
Nestet Virtualisierung an, man weiß ja nie und mindestens 16Gig RAM, sonst wird das nichts hier
Irgendwie muss man ja ein bisschen seinen RAM voll kriegen
So, zack, bumm, fertig
Porgu
Gut, und jetzt müssen wir uns mal kurz die ISO
Ah ja ja, by the way
Und jetzt müssen wir uns mal die ISO
Wenn man sie irgendwo hier findet
Windows, ja so einfach mal nach ISO
Alter, ist das kacke, äh, ISO
Äh, was, äh
Windows Insider Preview Client 64 ENGB 25951 ISO
Exakt, die brauchen wir, die und nicht anders
Äh, nein, ich will das nicht, ich will das hier anklicken und dann will ich das hier reintracken und droppen
Oh, nice
So, und jetzt kopiert er 5Gig hier rüber auf meine Windows-Kiste
Und in der Zwischenzeit hängt natürlich der Explorer, weil, wie sollte der auch im Hintergrund refreshen
Man könnte das ja asynchron machen, aber das hat Microsoft nicht nötig
Gut, dann machen wir Linux-Kiste aus
Und hängen mal die Disk ein und schauen uns mal an, was da dran jetzt so Porgu Neues ist
Oh, Leute, ich muss nochmal ganz schnell rüber, weil ich muss mich da wahrscheinlich gleich mit dem Microsoft-Account einloggen
Ich muss nochmal ganz schnell rüber und mir die E-Mail-Adresse copy-pasten
Mit der ich mein Fake-Microsoft-Account gemacht habe
So, perfekt, excellent
Settings, ISO-Image, Downloads, let's go
Warum überhaupt Microsoft? Weil man für Microsoft bei jedem Scheiß irgendeinen Account braucht
23H2, nicht 2H2, nicht 2H2
Ich habe es installiert
Ja, naja 23H2 kommt ja demnächst, wir haben 23 und H2
Und jetzt gibt es die erste Preview-Version, soweit ich das gelesen habe
Language to install... United Kingdom, United Kingdom, Keyboard... Nein, nein, nein, Urdu
Ja, ich kriege es nicht hin, da bin ich jetzt vorbei
Und jetzt die erste Preview-Version
Language to install. United Kingdom. United Kingdom. Keyboard. Nein, nein, nein. Urdu. Genau. German.
Was ich übrigens auch bis heute nicht checke ist, wenn ich im Windows Setup auswähle Input Method German,
dass ich dann, nachdem Windows installiert ist, nochmal Input Method German auswählen muss.
Zum Glück kommt mittlerweile nicht mehr Cortana.
Das war wirklich bei Windows Setup der mit Abstand größte Upfuck überhaupt.
Hi, I'm Cortana.
Ja, okay, ich gebe zu, ich gebe zu, Chat, es ist natürlich viel zu weit gedacht für Microsoft,
dass man die Sprache, beziehungsweise es geht ja nicht mal um die Sprache, es geht um das Tastaturlayout,
dass man das Tastaturlayout, mit dem man den Installer bedient, natürlich auch in seinem Betriebssystem haben will.
Das ist zu weit gedacht für Microsoft, verstehe.
Wir accepten das. Wir customisen es auf die einzelne Festplatte.
Und jetzt flutscht die Installation hoffentlich.
Speedrun. Windows install. Glitchless. High-Performance-Stream.
Ja, das ist das richtige Grinder-Mindset. Ne, Grindset-Mindset, oder wie war das?
Was ist an UK-Sprache besser versus US?
Die Default-Einheiten sind auch kacke, aber nicht ganz so kacke.
Ne, eigentlich ist kein Unterschied.
Die Uhrzeit stimmt ein bisschen besser.
Überein. Ich glaube, es macht gar keinen großen Unterschied.
Und jetzt mit UK installiert, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, ob es da irgendwelche Unterschiede gibt.
Also, eins muss man sagen, Windows in der 4M installieren, das flutscht halt immer richtig nice.
Weil schon alles an SSD-Treiber, voller Performance hat, nichts irgendwie nachgeladen werden muss
und einfach hier volle Pulle durchdrücken kann.
Echt? Gibt es überhaupt Unterschiede zwischen der englischen Windows-Version und der UK-Windows-Version?
Ne, du hast richtig gelesen. Windows, ja.
Stimmt, manche Wörter schreiben sich in UK ja anders.
Ja, du hast recht, ein paar Sachen werden dann tatsächlich anders sein.
Dass die Engländer Water irgendwie Water so komisch aussprechen.
Water. Ich kann das nicht nachmachen, ihr wisst.
Das sind ja eher die Australier.
Wobei manche in England sagen ja auch nicht Soccer, Football, sondern die sagen Footie.
Habe ich letztens irgendwo gehört.
Playing some Footie with my mates.
Indeed.
Ist das größer geworden, dieses Getting-Ready-Symbol?
Das war doch noch nie so fett.
Okay, nice. Ich glaube, ich glaube...
Oh ne, jetzt erstmal Reboot.
Ich mache mal hier kurz das Skalieren aus.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das buggt rum.
Windows in einer 4M ist auch absurd stabil.
Generell muss ich sagen, also Stabilitätsprobleme habe ich schon jahrelang mit Windows nicht mehr.
Es fuckt mich andere Sachen übertrieben ab unter Windows.
Aber die Stabilität ist...
Also...
Seit...
Ich weiß nicht.
Also ganz ehrlich, die Stabilität war eigentlich schon seit den Windows XP-Zeiten ganz okay.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die Leute immer für Riesenprobleme hatten mit
Oh, mein PC crasht die ganze Zeit.
Ja, wenn du beschissene Hardware hast, die schon halb kaputt ist,
der RAM irgendwie die Hälfte nicht mehr richtig funktioniert und nicht mehr richtig auslesen kannst,
da wird jedes Betriebssystem Probleme haben.
Ich hatte mal...
Guck mal, das ist jetzt auch so ein Ding, ne?
Ich hab... Na gut, das hat er hier in United Kingdom.
Äh...
Was wollte ich denn jetzt erzählen?
Genau, ich hatte mal einen Rechner.
Ist schon eine Weile her, war glaube ich nach dem Athlon XP-Rechner.
Und da hatte ich irgendwo einen RAM-Stick super billig bekommen.
Das war, das war ein...
Ich sag jetzt einfach mal 1.000...
1.048, also 2G-RAM-Stick.
Also für die damalige Zeit relativ groß.
Hab ich irgendwo super billig bekommen.
Das Problem war nur, der RAM-Stick war kaputt.
Teilweise. Teilweise kaputt.
Der Rechner ist immer gecrasht.
Und da hab ich damals nachgeguckt und hab festgestellt,
es gibt eine Option, natürlich irgendwie Registry, sonst was, Bootmanager, Windows.
Da kann man einstellen, dass wir...
Also der Linux ist das, by the way, total easy.
Kann man einstellen, dass der beim Booten die ersten so und so viel Megabyte von RAM skippt,
die erkannt wurden und die letzten so und so viel Megabyte RAM skippt und solche Geschichten.
Und da hab ich dann quasi einen Rechner betrieben,
mit einem kaputten 2Gig, also nicht nur, da waren ja mehrere RAM-Sticks drin,
mit einem davon, mit einem kaputten 2Gig RAM-Stick,
wo ich die ersten, keine Ahnung, ich sag jetzt einfach mal 400MB rausgemappt habe aus der Memory und sowas.
Ganz furchtbar abenteuerliche Sachen, aber einfach mehr RAM, ja.
Und während Windows installiert, nochmal...
Gele, wie heißt das auf Deutsch? Gelisch? Nee, äh...
Gelisch? Gelisch, oder?
Ich hätte gerne German, wenn das möglich ist.
Also, Funfact, noch so eine olle Geschichte von einem der alten Rechner, die ich hatte.
Ich hab mal eine Zeit lang Nvidia Onboard RAID betrieben.
Warum blendet sich das da oben übrigens nicht aus?
Was ist das für ein Kack? Sonst ist das immer weg.
Also es gab ja Zeiten, da gab es auf einem Mainboard mehrere Chipsetze
und da gab es auch Mainboards mit Nvidia Chipsets,
also Nvidia hat mir zeitlang mal wirklich Mainboard Chipsets hergestellt.
Und da hatte ich ein Mainboard mit Nvidia RAID, also Onboard RAID Möglichkeiten.
Und da habe ich benutzt, damals mit, lasst mich euch kein Mist erzählen,
ich glaube 2x80 oder 2x160 Gig, wahrscheinlich 2x160 Gig, Festplatten.
Ratet mal, welches RAID Level ich verwendet habe.
Name your device, keckel. 0, selbstverständlich.
RAID 0, korrekt. RAID 0.
RAID 0. So hatte ich 2x160 Gig, war irgendwie 320.
War wirklich auch, also von der reinen sequentiellen Transferrate und so,
war das wirklich gut.
Also das war für die damalige Zeit das Schnellste, was du machen konntest.
Aber, der Chipsatz, ich schieb es einfach mal auf den Chipsatz, ja.
Der hatte einen Bug in RAID, im RAID drinnen.
Ich kann es mir bis heute nicht genau erklären und zwar,
manchmal ist mein Rechner gefreezed.
Nicht so richtig 100%ig gefreezed, der hing richtig krass, so IO mäßig.
Nahezu gefreezed.
Und da musste ich den Rechner immer mega schnell resetten,
weil wenn ich das nicht gemacht habe, haben sich die Platten kaputt geschrieben.
Also der musste dann auch jedes Mal File Recovery machen und sowas nach so einem Crash.
Also ganz, ganz weird Champ, ich schieb das bis heute auf den Chipsatz.
Du musstest wirklich ganz, ganz stark darauf achten,
sobald der Rechner freezed, Instant Reset.
Hast du 2 Minuten zugeguckt, in der Hoffnung er fängt sich wieder,
hat er schon im Zweifelsfall deinen Bootloader kaputt gemacht und sowas.
Ganz weird Champ, also das war mega verbuggt.
Und das habe ich bestimmt 2 Jahre verwendet oder so, ich weiß nicht.
Wenn man kacken ist, ja wenn man kacken ist hast du Glück,
da ist der Rechner meistens nicht unter Lasten, es ist nichts passiert.
Aber das war ganz, ganz komisch.
Und ich habe das 2 Jahre betrieben oder sowas und ich bin da,
ich war da fein mit, ja ich weiß auch nicht, wie man das, über das abkann.
Und zumindest seitdem habe ich nie wieder Onboard RAID verwendet.
Das hat dann aber auch nicht mehr lange gedauert, dann gab es SSDs
und mit SSD ist RAID eh nur noch beschränkt sinnvoll.
Personal Use, ja aber das hat nicht viel, also Kazaar habe ich wenig benutzt,
aber gab ja noch andere Sachen.
Kennt noch jemand, wie hieß das?
Bear Share oder sowas?
Das war, wobei das könnte, nee das war,
wie, auf was basierte das?
Das war nicht Kazaar, das war, wie hieß das denn?
Es war auch nicht Torrent, es war, wie hieß das denn?
Emule, ja, ja, ja, ja, sowas war das, genau.
Bear Share Wikipedia, diesen Kram hat man damals verwendet.
Bis 2006 eine populäre Tauschbörse, basierend auf,
Moment, die gibt es noch?
Nee, die gibt es nicht mehr, hätte mich auch sehr gewundert.
Basierend auf Emule oder so?
Ach nee, hier, Knutella war das, Knutella.
Da gab es schon jede Menge, sehr fragwürdiger Software.
Nein, nein, nein, ich will nicht sein innen.
Moment, Chatgib, ich bin, Moment, ah, wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Ohne, wobei, komm, scheiß drauf.
Ich sei, ich sei nämlich innen.
Konnte man, man konnte das doch auch so auswählen, oder?
Das ging doch, das ging doch irgendwie relativ easy.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, konnte man das nicht einfach skippen, irgendwie mittlerweile wieder?
Nee, okay, okay, was muss ich machen?
Shift, F10, jetzt wird's, okay, Shift, F10 und jetzt?
Der Chat ist high IQ, da weißt du das.
Okay, was? O, O, hallo?
O, O, B, E, Slash, ach nee, Backslash, weil Windows.
O, O, Bypass, ach du Scheiße, was?
Bypass N, R, O.
Okay, Alter, das ist so dämlich, Mann.
Was, ich muss Internet disconnected, oh nee.
Das ist wirklich eine Wissenschaft für sich, den Scheiß zu installieren.
Das ist so, das ist so dumm einfach nur.
Ehrlich gesagt, komm, Scheiße, wir sind United Kingdom, alles gut.
Man hätte jetzt ja auch erwarten können, dass sich das Microsoft hier irgendwie gemerkt hat oder so.
Nope, no pass, skip.
I don't have Internet.
Oh, ich darf einen lokalen Account machen, nice, enter your name, kek.
Next, Passwort, 123456, 123456.
Das kann man, glaube ich, skippen einfach, ach, das kann man auch nicht mal skippen.
1, 2, 3, perfekt.
Ach so, wenn man kein Passwort eingibt, dann kann man das skippen, okay.
No, no, no, required, ist auch geil, dass überhaupt was required ist.
No, no, no.
Ah, wir haben's, nice.
Okay, und jetzt kann ich wieder anmachen.
Probier mal das neue Paint aus, jawoll.
Probier mal gleich aus.
Und das Allerwichtigste, Dark Theme Notepad gibt's jetzt ja wohl auch.
Aber vorher Forever Tools installieren, weil ansonsten haben wir eine ziemlich miese Auflösung.
Also in der Zeit, bis man sich da einen Microsoft Account gemacht hat oder das dazu überredet hat,
hat man tatsächlich Mint schon dreimal installiert.
Gibt's das schon lange?
Ich hab sogar ein Dark Mode Notepad, ne.
Läuft Docker unter Windows 11 dann stabiler?
Keine Ahnung, ich hab bisher immer einen Riesenbogen gemacht mit Docker unter Windows,
weil Docker unter Windows gibt es ja in der Art und Weise gar nicht.
Es ist ja das Docker Frontend und unter der Haube wird irgendeine Linux-VM gestartet oder sowas, gell.
Das ist ganz weird, also eigentlich macht's überhaupt keinen Sinn, Docker unter Windows zu verwenden.
So, da sind wir.
Das ist die Version mit 7-Zip, hoffe ich, hoffe ich, ja, das ist die letzte.
Die letzte Preview-Version, wenn nicht, loggen wir uns jetzt ein und machen nochmal einen Update.
Aber vorher installieren wir erstmal Forever Tools, weil ohne Forever Tools ist halt Kacke zu bedienen in der VM.
Ich persönlich mag auch eine richtig echte Linux-VM deutlich lieber als VSL.
Ja gut, was bringen denn Windows-Docker-Images?
Das ist ja wirklich langsam echt die Ausgeburt der Hölle, oder?
Ich mein, es gibt ja schon seit Jahren das Gerücht, Microsoft möchte Windows durch Linux ersetzen,
aber das wird halt auch immer ein Gerücht bleiben.
Ich persönlich wäre sofort dabei, wenn Windows Linux-mäßiger wird, aber das wird halt nicht passieren.
Weil die ganze Enterprise-Business-Welt halt auch Windows-Scheiße irgendwie aufsetzt,
so mit Active Directory, benutzerberechte Verwaltung und sonst was.
Es ist natürlich, wie soll ich sagen, eine gewisse Überlegung ist ja da schon dahinter.
Microsoft verdient hauptsächlich ihr Geld mittlerweile mit Software, Services und Cloud.
Warum noch ein Betriebssystem? Aber ganz ehrlich, Microsoft ist ja kein,
also Microsoft ist das letzte Unternehmen, was einheitliche Entscheidungen trifft.
Ihr kennt doch dieses lustige Meme-Bild, ich finde das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Companies, Microsoft, Divisions, Meme, das da.
Die Struktur innerhalb verschiedener Unternehmen.
Also bei Amazon ist es relativ klassisch so, mit Teams, bei Google sind es die zwei Gründer und dann ganz verzweigt.
Bei Facebook blickt keiner so richtig durch, jeder mit jedem.
Und bei Microsoft hast du mehrere Abteilungen, die sich untereinander nicht abkönnen.
Und genau so ist es. Zumindest war es immer so und wenn man den Berichten glaubt,
ist es immer noch ein bisschen in Microsoft so.
Deswegen hat Microsoft ja auch so unglaublich viele, wie soll ich sagen, so parallel laufende Dinger.
Drei verschiedene Notizprogramme, jeder verwendet ein bisschen eigenen Installer.
Microsoft hat auch massig React-Native-Apps anstatt die eigenen Klampel zu verwenden.
Microsoft kann sich untereinander nicht ab.
Keck ist am Start.
Ist das die neue Bing-AI hier unten?
Search with AI.
Es ist so schlimm, man muss so viel Scheiße wegklicken jedes Mal.
Okay, kann ich jetzt mit AI searchen?
Pogu.
Äh, hallo?
Oh, jetzt habe ich sie überfordert.
Pogu is a popular Twitch-Emote.
Na, immerhin.
Okay, wir fragen die jetzt mal.
Why is Windows so good?
Ja, ja, wir accepten die Terms of Service.
Die musste ich vorher nicht akzeptieren.
Okay, Bing, erklär uns das mal.
Bing weiß es auch nicht.
Bing hat kein...
Das ist so eine typische Schwurbel-Antwort, würde man sagen.
Drumherum gelabert as fuck.
Learn about this picture.
Jawohl, wollte ich schon immer.
Edge hat kein Symbol mehr?
Braucht man ja auch nicht.
Es ist ja immer komplett overrated, outdated, wenn irgendwie Software-Symbole hat.
Achso, jetzt...
War's auch immer.
So.
Jetzt müssen wir Insider...
Dieser Schrott...
Leute, gibt es irgendjemand auf dieser Welt, der diese Sidebar und die Widgets verwendet?
Niemand verwendet die, oder?
Und das hier unten, das hier unten verwendet auch niemand.
Insider.
Äh, Insider.
Ja, okay, mach ich.
Diagnostic Feedback muss aktiviert werden.
Please link a Microsoft work account.
Okay, ähm...
Microsoft account.
Continue.
Ich hab mir das Passwort und alles gemerkt, sehr gut.
Yep.
Use this account.
Was? Use this account everywhere on your device.
Ja, okay.
Pass auf, jetzt kommt ich darf nicht, oder so.
Nice. Okay, jetzt müssen wir nochmal updaten.
A new build is available.
Pog.
Check for updates.
Aber das macht doch das Sign-in vom Anfang rückgängig.
Nee.
Nee, jetzt...
Ich glaube, jetzt kann ich mich immer noch mit dem Passwort einloggen.
Mit meinem normalen Passwort.
Lokalen Passwort.
Ohne, dass ich jedes Mal meinen Microsoft account Passwort gedönst eingeben muss.
So, das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich 5 Minuten dauern.
Es gab zig Anläufe von Microsoft mit Widgets auf dem Desktop.
Die ersten waren mit Vista.
Die fand ich persönlich gar nicht so doof.
Da konntest du auch sehr viel machen mit.
Dann gab es mit Windows 7 und 8...
Mit 8 gab es diese Kachel-Widgets, die niemand verwenden wollte.
Mit 7 war, glaube ich, ein bisschen verbesserte Vista-Widgets.
Und seitdem...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es unter Windows 10 Gescheite gab.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man es aufmacht.
Ist das nicht der Widget-Knopf?
Das ist gar nicht der Widget-Knopf.
Ich habe mich vertan, übrigens, Leute.
Das hier ist Widgets.
Angeblich gibt es den Knopf, aber ich sehe es nicht.
Es ist doch Widgets.
Doch, Widgets.
Play.
So ein Schrott, Alter.
Moment.
Das macht einfach nur einen Browser auf.
Das ist so schlecht alles.
Das ist so...
Da fehlen mir die Worte für.
Das ist so gewollt und nicht gekonnt.
Irrelevant und überflüssig.
Und nervig und alles.
Niemand verwendet das.
Turn on backup.
No.
Die gibt es ja auch nicht.
Jede Mac-Version neu.
Sondern stetig verbessert.
Ist das jetzt fertig?
Oder Update?
Ah, hier.
Restart.
Wir warten aber noch mal, bis die Installation durch ist.
Dann machen wir einen Restart.
Und dann hoffe ich...
Was ist eigentlich mit meinem Hintergrund-Symbol los?
Warum kacken die jedes Mal so ab?
Und dann hoffe ich,
dass das alles an neuen Features da ist.
Und funktioniert.
Ja, Baldi-Sauce, das ist angeblich so.
Das werden wir gleich ausprobieren.
Es fühlt sich wie ein Baustein,
der nicht zum Betrieb ist.
Das trifft es, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Preinstallte immer noch Candy Crash.
Weiß ich nicht.
Aber Disney Plus und Netflix und sowas.
Link in...
Neues Paint ist angeblich geil.
Das ist aber noch nicht das neue Paint, oder?
Dann müssen wir erst mal hier warten,
Netflix.
Äh.
Bei mir hat das letzte Mal Disney Plus mit installiert.
Und diese standardmäßig aktivierte Suche
kriegt mich auch auf.
Dass der jedes Suchergebnis
ins Internet postet.
Gibt es einen Grund, auf Windows 11 zu gehen?
Ja, weil der Support für Windows 10
nicht mal lange läuft.
Restart.
Bis 2025, glaube ich, ne?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe UK installiert.
Ich habe mit
English International installiert.
Windows 10 Support?
Ende 2025.
Es kann sogar sein, dass es der Extended Support ist
und der eigentliche Support nächstes Jahr schon ausläuft.
Aber ne, ne.
Bin ich mir nicht sicher.
2025 ist auf jeden Fall
ein Termin.
Die Windows KI
habe ich nicht großartig vor, das zu benutzen.
Aber mal schauen.
Okay. So, wir haben es geschafft.
Okay, als erstes mal hier.
Personalize.
You need to activate Windows.
Seriously.
Ich muss Windows...
Ich muss Windows aktivieren.
Auch in einer Preview...
Ha, das ist so bescheuert.
In einer Preview Variante
für Dark Theme und sowas.
Warum ist das so dumm?
Wenn ich jetzt sage
Activate, was passiert dann?
Wahrscheinlich nix.
Nee, nix.
Hat kein Bock zu aktivieren.
Ach, das geht.
Theme Select
geht noch.
Habe ich jetzt auch Dark Theme Notepad?
Oh, guck mal, Leute.
Das Startmenü ist jetzt auch...
Wobei, nee, war es vorher glaube ich auch schon.
Dark Theme.
So, jetzt haben wir neues Paint angeblich.
Nö, ich sehe hier kein neues Paint.
Das ist das ganz normale Paint.
Das ist in irgendeiner Art und Weise neu.
Lasst uns mal schauen, ob die Updates
eigentlich jetzt abgeschlossen sind.
Nee.
Doch.
So, angeblich
kann man jetzt Symbole
entgruppieren.
Das werden wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Übrigens, lasst euch...
Ach, die Fender.
Lasst euch nicht veräppeln,
das hier unten ist nicht Teams.
Das sieht nur aus wie Teams.
Das ist nämlich
Microsoft Teams, nicht
Microsoft Teams.
Nicht Teams, das ist Fake Teams.
Das kann man gleich
wegmachen, weil es gibt zwei.
Es gibt zwei Teams.
Es gibt ein echtes Microsoft Teams
und es gibt ein Microsoft Teams,
was nicht Microsoft Teams ist.
Und es kommt das nicht Microsoft Teams
mit Windows mit.
Ich hoffe, man hat das jetzt verstanden.
Das ist so.
Ich kann es euch nicht besser erklären.
Es gibt zweimal Microsoft Teams bei
Microsoft, aber nur das eine ist
wirklich echtes Microsoft Teams.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das so ist.
Das nicht Microsoft Teams kann
weniger
als Teams.
Ich weiß nicht, was der Unterschied ist.
Okay, wir gucken mal kurz rein
hier. Teams. Okay,
Finish Setup.
Ihr seht vielleicht, es sieht auch schon gar nicht aus
wie Microsoft Teams.
Warum können die nicht denken,
ich weiß nicht, was bei Microsoft
los ist.
In-Before-Name-Leak. Ja, ich heiße
Wubkek mit dem Account.
Hoffentlich
leake ich den nicht.
Es macht halt keinen Sinn, zwei verschiedene
Teamversionen zu haben. Man kann ja mit dem
Enterprise Teams
Outlook
Ja, ja, mach mal alles. Es juckt mich eh nicht,
was mit dem Account.
Mit dem Outlook, mit dem
Teams auch private Leute anschauen. Das macht
überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ihr werdet feststellen, es sieht nicht
aus wie Teams.
Und es verhält sich auch nicht wie Teams.
Aber es ist,
es heißt Teams, aber es ist nicht Teams.
Wie
euch vielleicht...
Es sieht aus wie Skype.
Es gibt aus irgendwelchen Gründen
irgendwie so ein Community
Button und
keinen
Thema, was das vielleicht ist.
So, das muss jetzt
erstmal gequittet werden.
So, dann checken wir doch mal, ob
das Wichtigste geht. Wir machen jetzt Google auf.
Und wir machen nochmal
Google auf. Und dann machen wir zwei
verschiedene Fenster...
Moment.
Dann machen wir zwei verschiedene Fenster auf.
Und jetzt hoffe ich,
man kann es entgruppieren.
Please.
Erstmal Widgets weg.
Taskview kann da bleiben.
Searchbox braucht kein Mensch.
Wobei, das können wir mit der AI.
Wobei, die AI juckt mich nicht.
Und das Allerwichtigste ist...
Ja, taskbar.
Automatically
left. Okay.
Ah!
Jawoll!
Es ist verbuggt.
Das Icon fehlt beim zweiten Fenster.
Hahaha.
Das sieht so schlecht, Alter.
Es ist einfach
so schlecht.
Okay.
Chrome download.
Die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht
da, Leute.
Kann man nicht erwarten, dass das funktioniert.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass
es im fertigen Release gefixt ist.
Wobei man sich halt echt fragt, warum
sowas überhaupt... Also, das ist das Erste,
was man sehen müsste, wenn man das
startet und es halt nicht funktioniert.
Mal gucken. Vielleicht geht es mit Chrome ja besser.
Was? Would you like to pin?
Yes.
Unbedingt. Yes.
Bin ganz scharf drauf, dass Chrome
gepinnt wird. Gatschibass.
Äh, was?
Ah! Okay.
So.
Ah ja, guckt mal.
Mit Chrome funktioniert
es besser. Leute, ich hab...
Ich bin ja so...
Das ist für mich...
Naja, das... Guckt mal.
So richtig gescheit funktionieren
tut es ja aber noch nicht, oder?
Man kriegt jetzt beide Fenster
angezeigt und weiß jetzt nicht so richtig,
welches davon welches ist, wenn die sich ähnlich sehen.
Also so wirklich...
Und ich versteh halt nicht. Das gab es halt schon.
Das gab es halt schon seit
20 Jahren in Windows und das hat einfach funktioniert.
Ich versteh nicht, warum das...
Ich versteh eh nicht, warum es eine
komplett neue Taskbar mit jedem Windows
irgendwie braucht. War noch ein drittes
auf. Auch nicht mal...
Die Seitenverhältnisse sind hier unten
drinnen auch so merkwürdig.
Nutzt du auf Linux einen Display Manager?
Du meinst so zum Einloggen
und sowas?
Nee, aber ich kann dir zeigen, wie ich das mache.
Ich finde das
für mein Setup viel besser, wie ich es
hab. Ich brauch keinen Display Manager.
Ich mach das so. Guck, ich zeig's dir mal.
Ich starte jetzt X.
Oder ich reboote.
Dass du siehst, wie es bei mir ausschaut.
Das ist 23 Hz.
Ja, Public doch. Im Preview Channel
kannst du mal. Aber die wird noch nicht
erzählt. Guck, wenn ich mal Linux starte,
sieht es so aus. Dann gäbe ich ganz normales
Konsole
Login.
Auf dem
Kernel-Buffer-Terminal.
So, loggst du dich ein.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Super-Secret-Passwort.
Und dann sagst du
Start X. Ich hatte es früher so
gemacht, dass es automatisch startet
nach dem Login, wenn ich auf dem ersten
TTY bin. Aber wozu?
So, fertig.
Also,
wozu brauch ich irgendeinen komischen
Display Manager, wenn ich einfach
Start X eintippen kann. Alles ist da.
Okay, das ist für mich tatsächlich
das mit Abstand interessanteste
Feature in ganz
Windows 23
H2, dass man endlich
diese doofen Task-Dinger
wieder entkopieren kann. Und man die
ordentlich, naja, ordentlich
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten,
ob das hier eine ordentliche Vorschau ist und alles.
Aber immerhin, ja.
Immerhin.
Besser als davor
ist es auf jeden Fall.
So, der hässliche Microsoft Store ist
immer noch da, den keiner braucht. Edge
braucht auch keiner.
Mach mal 20 Tabs auf.
Da passiert ja nix, weil
Tabs tauchen ja nicht hier unten auf.
Sind ja nur unterschiedliche Fenster. Du meinst, ich soll mal
20 Fenster aufmachen? Okay.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das nicht vielleicht auch anders
machen kann. Ja, nice, guck mal!
Jetzt kann man endlich seine Task-Leiste
wieder für was Sinnvolles verwenden.
Meine Task-Leiste ist einfach die ganze Zeit
empty
und wird für nichts benutzt.
Also, das ist ja wirklich mal eine gute
Sache.
Mach mal Edge auf.
Note-Items sind immer noch brauchen.
Mehrere Tabs in Edge.
Gibt auch nicht.
Ist doch gut so.
Es ist natürlich ein bisschen doof, dass in der Vorschau
jetzt alle Tabs drin sind
und nur das eine highlighted wird.
Auf der anderen Seite vielleicht gar nicht
so schlecht, weil
wenn man wirklich das so hat, nicht genau weiß, welches
es ist, kann man so klicken.
Kannst du ein anderes geöffnetes Programm
zwischen die Chromes packen? Das glaube ich nicht.
Das ist Windows, das wird im Leben nicht funktionieren.
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Das geht
selbstverständlich nicht.
Das wäre jetzt ja auch
zu advanced.
Das ging zwar unter Windows 98, aber
das heißt noch lange nicht,
dass das in Windows 11
geht. Wir müssen
was anderes probieren. Kann man denn mittlerweile Sachen
hier raufziehen? Geht das immer noch nicht?
Moment, ich muss das mal
schließen, weil...
Ah, guck mal!
Möglicherweise macht der jetzt auch nur einen
zu immer. Okay, nice.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen, aber
nicht den, den ich angekl...
Hä? Die Icon
sind PP gar, aber naja, gut.
Kann ich denn
jetzt Sachen wieder hier draufziehen?
Ja, okay, das funktioniert mittlerweile.
Unpin.
Was allerdings immer noch nicht
funktioniert, glaube ich, wenn wir hier mal
irgendwas anlegen.
Ja,
.txt,
das geht nicht.
Das ging zwar auch unter Windows
98 schon, aber das ist einfach
zu... Wie gesagt, die...
Das gibt die
Technologie nicht her heutzutage,
dass man direkt hier unten was verlegen kann.
Ja, ich weiß, du kannst, glaube ich,
eine Verknüpfung machen und die Verknüpfung da drauf...
Ne, geht auch nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Way
too advanced. Das geht einfach nicht.
Einfach
einfach nicht...
Das ist nicht possible. Das geht nicht.
So, das ist doch schon mal gut. So, was haben wir denn sonst
noch Neues? Was haben wir
denn sonst noch Neues in Windows? Lass uns mal
bei diesem komischen
PC-Welt-Artikel da bleiben.
Ich meine, PC-Welt ist nun wirklich nicht das,
was ich mir angehe, normalerweise
geben würde, aber ich glaube, die Übersicht
hier ist ganz okay. Genau, 7-Zip.
Richtig, 7-Zip wollten wir
nochmal ausprobieren.
Gibt es ein gutes 7-Zip
GitHub irgendwas
zum Downloaden
in 7-Zip-Format?
Demo...
Was gibt es denn
in 7-Zip selber? Gibt es doch bestimmt ein 7-Zip,
oder?
Ne, gibt es nicht.
Welche Software
wird denn als 7-Zip ausgeliefert?
Wobei, auf der anderen Seite, wir können ja gucken,
wir müssten ja selbst was zippen können mit
7-Zip, oder? Übrigens
das zweite Menü
gibt es immer noch. Und was halt
auffällt ist, dieses Menü
ist so unglaublich
unresponsive und langsam
versus
dieses alte Menü hier. Seht ihr das?
Okay, es ist nicht
so Tablet-freundlich, aber
scheiß doch drauf, wen interessiert
Tablet-freundlich?
Auf dem Desktop.
So, also Compress-zu-Zip-File.
Kann man das?
Ne, ist nur als Zip.
Compress?
Kann Windows?
Moment, es kann nur entpacken? Ja? Wirklich?
Win-Zip.
Mein Lieblings-Windows?
XP. Not even close.
XP ist das
einheitlichste
Windows und
freundlichste und innovativste
Windows, was Microsoft je gemacht hat.
Ich meine innovativste,
kann man nicht drüber schreien, viele sagen sicherlich Windows 95.
Probier mal 7-Zip
mit Win-Get zu installieren, das ist eine gute Idee.
Was ist denn das?
Power
Automate.
Okay, was haben wir hier? Power Automate.
Ja, Win-Get ist soweit.
Ich war jetzt standardmäßig drauf.
Ich hab's jetzt gestartet.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was ich da überhaupt gestartet hab.
Okay.
Ähm.
No, God, please, no!
Und tschüss.
Okay, Win-Get install
7-Zip. Yes.
Ich agree alles.
Okay, es ist 7-Zip.
Übrigens,
jeder Linux-User, der dort einen
gescheiten Package-Manager hat,
lacht sich kaputt immer über Win-Get.
Aber es ist halt immer noch das Beste, was es unter Windows so gibt.
So.
Und jetzt, wie kann ich show more options?
7-Zip. Ach so.
Ja, klar. Selbstverständlich ist 7-Zip
natürlich im Normalen
nicht drin.
Da muss man in das alte Menü. Obviously.
Compress to new folder 7-Zip.
Guck mal, Leute!
Windows kann 7-Zip
entpacken. Zwar nicht erstellen,
aber entpacken.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz nice,
dass das funktioniert.
Ja, wir können auch mal sagen hier,
es ist so laggy, dieses Menü.
7-Zip, okay, das hängt nach wie vor drin.
Was ist denn das Start-Backup?
Das da? Meinst du das da?
Windows Backup.
Let's backup your PC.
Storage estimate.
Ach, das schiebt
auf OneDrive irgendwas hoch.
Ist das auch neu?
Nein,
oben im Windows Explorer
in der Fahrtleiste stand das.
Okay. Ah, hier!
Was lädt
er da eigentlich so lang?
Oh, Windows macht irgendwas gerade.
Irgendwas macht er.
Start-Backup.
Ja, das ist irgendein OneDrive-Shit.
Ah, der schickt das jetzt irgendwie
bei OneDrive hin.
Ja, OneDrive Backup.
Ja.
Naja.
Werde ich definitiv nicht benutzen.
Power Automate?
Das ist ein bisschen...
Also so wirklich
gut fand es der Explorer noch nicht, oder?
Kann das sein, dass der Explorer nichts mehr anzeigt?
Doch.
Wupp.
Ja, das ist auch neu.
Das ist der neue Galerie-Explorer.
Okay,
das machen wir jetzt ganz einfach.
Wir installieren uns
die...
Github Wooblords.
Wir installieren uns...
Was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Chat, ich hab nicht geguckt, was jetzt passiert.
WordPad noch drinnen.
Gucken wir mal.
Ja, WordPad ist noch am Start.
New Desktop Background.
Images.
Da müssen wir gleich mal gucken, ob
Shit mitkommt. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Es würde mich...
Es würde mich hart
wundern, wenn man unter Windows einfach
Git... Wait a minute.
Ah, das...
Das hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert,
wenn man unter Windows einfach so Git Clone
machen könnte.
Ich mach das jetzt mal wie der größte
Kacknudel, der keine Ahnung hat, was er macht.
Ob das auch so ist? Ich weiß es unter Windows nicht.
Okay.
Muss ich jetzt Git.Git machen
oder wie? Oh, das ist diese komische
Git Bash. Das ist der...
Der...
Mülligste Variante
Git zu verwenden überhaupt.
Bug macht den Dateiexplorer
in Windows 11 schneller.
Okay, man muss Fullscreen machen, dann wird
der Explorer schneller. Nice.
Okay, Git Clone.
Wie jetzt? Warum geht das nicht?
Muss ich jetzt hier Git...
Oh, das ist...
Das ist so schlecht. Oh Gott, ist das schlecht.
Ich krieg Anfälle
unter Windows, wenn ich sowas hier sehe.
Das ist Cygwin. Moment!
Das ist noch irgendein olles Cygwin.
WTF, wer benutzt denn sowas?
Ganz ehrlich, Windows User
müssen echt hart leidensfähig sein, was
sowas angeht.
Das ist wirklich... Das ist eine unglaubliche
Zumutung, das zu benutzen.
Wie langsam das ist.
Mach mal PowerShell auf.
Ach, jetzt...
Hä? Achso, wir
sind hier unter... Ist das jetzt
das, was im Path drin ist?
Das heißt, wenn ich das hier auch
neu aufmache... Achso.
Ah, dann bräuchte ich... Okay,
das ist tatsächlich dann angenehmer.
Ja, okay. So.
Aber ich wollte ja mal den Gallery View
ausprobieren. Add Folder.
Keg W.
White Paper Happy. Images.
Äh, okay.
Das funktioniert sehr gut.
Wo ist mein Heimatverzeichnis,
Leute? Wo ist mein Heimatverzeichnis?
Das ist nicht mein
Heimatverzeichnis. Wo ist denn mein Heimatverzeichnis?
OneDrive?
Wait a minute.
Ich würde gerne hier
das verlinken. Geht das nicht
mehr?
Ja, mein Userverzeichnis... Okay,
das geht. Die Images
hätte ich da gern drin.
Das funzt einfach nicht.
Was, du musst auf Add gehen?
Nee.
Schon richtig so.
Okay, also das funzt einfach nicht.
So kann ich es aber hierhin kopieren,
ne? Und kann ich es überhaupt
dahin droppen, wenn ich...
Man kann es nicht über Desktop schieben.
Das heißt, ich muss es drunter in Desktop
dann vorbeischieben. Es ist teilweise
so... Amateurhaft
wirkt das, Alter. Unglaublich.
Kann nur JPEG und kein PNG.
Das glaube ich nicht. Oder?
Was ist überhaupt der Sinn
davon? Man konnte
doch seit Ewigkeiten unter Windows schon irgendwelche
Imagefolders adden.
Add Phone Photos.
Also das hier hat schon mal nicht funktioniert.
Können wir noch irgendwas anderes hinzufügen?
Ist da irgendwas drinnen noch so?
Also... Ne.
Scheint nicht zu funktionieren.
Ich hab zwei
Image... Ich hab ein Imagefolder
noch hier drin und das hat nicht funktioniert.
Ne, das mag nicht.
Das hat keinen Bock.
Und die Background-Symbole
gehen auch nicht.
Also das funktioniert
so nicht.
Obwohl, lustigerweise, wenn man direkt
in den Ordner geht...
Wie krieg ich denn das hier neben wieder weg, by the way?
Wie krieg ich denn das hier neben wieder weg?
Alter, warum hat denn das kein
Schließen-Button hier neben?
Achso, doch Details da oben.
Geil, usability.
Äh, what the fuck?
Images.
Ja, mal anzeigen kannst du es hier offensichtlich.
Naja.
Okay.
Das ist aber auch blöd, dass die Task-Leiste
permanent springt. Guck mal!
Seht ihr, wie langsam das ist?
Guckt euch das mal an! Guckt mal!
Alter!
Das dauert ja drei Jahre, bis das
resized ist.
Haben die irgendwie fähige Leute, die da dran
sitzen oder sowas? Was ist denn das?
Das wirkt einfach so krass.
Ich meine, ganzes Windows 11 wirkt schon
seit Anfang an. Das ist Absicht.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es Absicht. Sieht aber beschissen aus.
Animation.
Animation and effects. Okay.
Okay, Animation sind aus.
Vielleicht geht es jetzt besser.
Hey! Guck mal!
Wenn die Animationen aus sind, gleich...
Okay, bestes, wichtigstes,
richtig und wichtiges Feature.
Erstmal Animationen ausschalten.
Dann ist auch alles viel schneller!
Hui! Wer hätte das gedacht?
Und guck mal! Sogar die Windows-Background-Symbole
gehen dann wieder.
Sind die Menüs besser?
Es gibt jetzt, um es übersichtlicher zu machen,
dieses Menü, um danach wieder in das
alte Menü gehen zu können.
Weil Microsoft Fivehead Time.
Okay, was gibt es sonst
noch Neues? Lasst uns mal hier reingucken.
Also, AI Copilot.
Ist denn der schon drin?
Nein.
Oder war das das, was ich ausgeplanet habe?
Der AI Copilot?
Moment, Moment.
So, ja.
Search.
Porgu.
Das ist nicht der AI Copilot.
Oben rechts
meinst du das da?
Search with AI.
Ja, da geht aber einfach nur ein...
Da geht einfach nur ein Edge auf damit.
Also das wird es nicht sein.
Das wird es nicht sein.
Windows Open
AI Copilot.
Was darf man sich darunter vorstellen?
War oben links, als du eingegeben hast.
Warte mal.
Wir machen jetzt mal was. Wo ist denn hier der Button
für...
View Exclusive Mode.
Dann kann ich hier nicht mehr raus.
Okay, Porgu.
Das da.
Chat with AI.
Search with AI.
I will disengage
from this conversation.
Ah, Porgu.
Not found.
Announcing Windows Copilot.
Okay, so sollte das.
Radiantracer,
Dankeschön für 25 Jahre
Subscription.
So sollte das eigentlich aussehen.
Das ist nicht
das, was wir hier haben.
Guck mal, man bekommt hier so ein Ding.
Was ich nie im Leben
wahrscheinlich verwenden werde.
Aber okay, ich meine
AI. Ich vermute, das ist noch
nicht drin. Viel
interessanter, mal kurz
das Wichtigste anpassen. Kann man überhaupt
Moment, kann ich überhaupt den Background
changen?
Nee, ich kann den Background nicht changen, wenn ich
nicht Windows aktiviert hab.
Doch, man kann bestimmt
tricksen, Leute. Wo ist denn mein Explorer?
Jetzt, da.
Man kann bestimmt tricksen, indem man
auf Downloads geht und sagt
Set as Background.
Sehr gut.
Endlich ein gescheiter Hintergrund.
Nee, ich brauch keine Lizenz.
Das ist ein Fake Account oder eine temporäre
Installation. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch so?
Das gibt's anscheinend nicht.
KI-geschützte Dateiempfehlung
im Dateiexplorer und Start.
Okay, KI-geschützt.
Blub. Das wurde jetzt per
KI gefunden?
Wozu brauche ich
KI-Unterstützung, wenn ich eine Datei
auf meiner Festplatte suche?
Das ist doch ein
gelöstes Problem.
Was ist der Play-Button hier oben?
Design ist einschließbar.
Galerie-Modus funktioniert bei uns nicht.
Die dynamische Beleuchtung
integrierter Tools. Gut,
das kann ich in der VM nicht ausprobieren, da habe ich keinen
Zugriff auf meine Hardware zum RGB-Steuern.
Aufheben, das haben wir ausprobiert.
Das ist wirklich endlich.
Endlich mal
dabei, dass man das endkopieren kann.
Endlich. Also, das ist ja
eines der Sachen, die mich am meisten abgefuckt hat
oder Windows 11 seit Anbeginn.
Unterstützung von
7-Zip und RAR finde ich auch gut.
GZ?
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Ich dachte, die haben schon
TGZ-Support und sowas.
Die ganze Zeit schon, aber anscheinend nicht.
Möglichkeit zum Ausblenden
von Datum und Uhrzeit in der Taskleiste.
Okay.
Edinburgh.
Ja.
Moment, die Uhr kann angeblich doch
jetzt auch Sekunden, dachte ich.
Moment, kann die Uhr jetzt nicht auch Sekunden?
War da nicht was?
Wait a minute, ging das nicht jetzt?
Moment, wo geht denn das jetzt?
Ich dachte, das geht jetzt, dass sie auch
Sekunden anzeigen kann.
In den Taskleisten. Okay,
selbstverständlich ist die Sekundenanzeige
nicht unter Date und Time,
sondern unter Taskleissettings.
Obviously.
Ja.
Ah.
Uses more power.
Microsoft, please.
Please.
Keck Alu.
Jetzt aber wirklich.
Als würde so ein fucking
Timer in der CPU nicht laufen,
nur weil Microsoft ihn nicht ausliest.
Uses more power.
Die haben doch wirklich den Arsch auf.
Okay, das sieht tatsächlich ganz brauchbar
aus.
Hide Icon Menu. Was?
Ach, das da.
Nee, das wollen wir nicht.
Das wollen wir nicht. Hiden.
Touch Keypad.
Never.
Pen Menu off. Ganz Müll.
Ja, das ist
ganz okay, das kann man lassen.
So,
das haben wir uns angeguckt.
Neue AI-Funktion
in Microsoft Store.
AI-generierte App-Schlüsselwörter
und Bewertungszusammenfassung.
Who cares?
Microsoft Store
und AI
und was auch immer.
Sichern und wiederherstellen von Apps.
Installiert beim Wiederherstellen
eines Backups alle Apps neu,
die sie aus dem Microsoft Store entzählt haben.
Gut, ich habe so gut wie nichts aus dem Microsoft Store
entzählt, also insofern.
Wie macht man eigentlich so einen Backup?
Das würde mich jetzt echt mal interessieren. Ich habe noch nie einen Backup gemacht
unter Windows mit Windows Board.
Windows Backup.
Früher gab es diese System-Snapshots.
Okay, okay.
Wir testen das jetzt mal.
Wir machen das mal auf dem Desktop.
Kackel.txt 123.
Beste.
Das wird jetzt gebackupt.
Backup.
Äh.
Eben war es doch noch da.
Moment, es heißt nicht Backup, sondern
ja, da ist die AI einfach nicht
AI genug für, dass sie Backup und Backup
versteht.
AI
Suggestions.
Was ist denn der Unterschied
zwischen
diesem Backup
und
warum ist denn das übrigens OneDrive
Desktop?
What?
Moment, warum liegt denn jetzt auf einmal
alles auf OneDrive?
Ich will das schon auch lokal haben.
OneDrive Desktop?
Ich habe es, ich habe es für einen
Ordner aktiviert.
Oder mal, okay,
okay,
und wie deaktiviere ich das wieder?
Ja.
Das ist,
das ist wieder der Grund, warum ich so Sachen erst
gar nicht ausprobiere unter Windows, weil
den Scheiß immer dann wegkriegst.
Ich,
ah hier, okay,
Desktop, Desktop weg.
Was?
Alter, was ein
abartiges Rumgefrickel.
Ja, ist ja gut,
man. Okay, neue Datei
anlegen. Ich habe noch nie einen
Backup restored unter Windows. So, die
Datei, so, die ist hier. Okay, Backup.
Aber was ist der Unterschied
zwischen dem Backup über den Explorer und den
ist das hier rein lokal
oder ist das jetzt auch OneDrive?
Okay, Backup.
Ich meine sieben,
erft doch nicht rum, Alter.
Verify your identity.
Okay. Kann ich das,
kann ich das wieder disablen?
Ich will doch kein Backup
davon machen, Leute. Es geht darum,
zu gucken, was die Windows-Funktionen sind.
Ich will doch nicht wirklich ein Backup davon machen.
Okay, jetzt nochmal.
Backup is more than protection.
Warum brauchen
der so, warum brauchen der da so lang für?
Ach, das waren bloß sieben MB.
Sieben MB habe ich in zwei
Sekunden hochgehabt.
Die große Preisfrage ist doch jetzt,
wie restore ich hier irgendwie
wieder was?
Restore?
Ach, Restore Points und sowas gibt es auch
noch. Recovery?
Ah, das ist die Windows XP
Backup und Recovery Geschichte.
Es ist so ein hässliches,
ekliges,
Wildwuchsbetriebssystem, man.
Ich benutze
ja im Prinzip nichts, was
eingebaut ist unter Windows.
Weil du nie weißt, ob du das Richtige benutzt
und ob das morgen noch da ist,
ob das noch supported ist oder sonst was.
Es ist einfach so beschissen.
Was anderes kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Und warum braucht der
für meine Apps drei Stunden zum Backupen?
Und viel interessanter, wie restore ich
überhaupt ein Backup wieder?
Okay, wir fragen mal.
Windows Backup
Restore
Backup and Restore in Windows
Control Panel
Es ist so lächerlich.
Was macht der denn da jetzt drei Stunden?
Kennst du ein gutes Backup-Tool
für Windows?
Ich kann dir
sagen,
was ich manchmal mache.
Ich backupe mein
HP
Microserver ab und zu mal auf eine externe
Platte und schieb von Windows Sachen
rüber, die ich brauche
und synke das. Aber ansonsten
kann ich dir sagen,
was ich unter Linux verwende oder was ich unter Linux mag.
Unter Linux gibt es zwei coole Sachen,
die ich gerne verwende. Das ist einmal das da
und
das da für Offsite
Cloud
Geschichten. In letzter Zeit
habe ich mir auch nochmal angeguckt
Copia Backup
Besser Name
Auch nicht schlecht.
Geht glaube ich auch alles
unter Windows?
Was macht denn dieses Backup-Tool
da eigentlich? Was hat das
für Probleme?
Rundum geschützt. Ja, nice.
Rundum geschützt. Ich weiß nicht mal. Okay.
Leute. Hups.
Jetzt habe ich was.
Ich verstehe
nicht, was Windows von mir will.
Es ist so mies. Es ist so schlecht.
Einfach alles.
So, okay. Jetzt ist die Frage,
wie restore ich die Datei? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, es gibt
es gibt
Backup. Nein.
Es gibt Backup.
Aber es gibt kein Restore.
Das ist ja schön, dass ich
Backupen kann, aber ich kann halt nicht Restoren.
Ja, ich habe nach Restore gesucht.
Da gibt es halt nichts.
Es gibt Recovery, aber das ist das alte.
Reset this PC
gibt es. Ne, das will ich ja
nicht. Okay, Restore.
Restore your files
with file history. Nein.
Das ist wieder was.
Das ist noch eine andere Möglichkeit.
Okay, kann ich jetzt
vielleicht in OneDrive
gehen und gucken, ob es da ist?
Ne.
Da ist es natürlich nicht da.
Ich müsste jetzt in OneDrive in irgendeiner
Dateihistory und es ist einfach
so dumm, ganz ehrlich. Vergiss es.
Scheiß, würde ich nie verwenden.
Also ich kann wahrscheinlich jetzt in OneDrive.
Ach, hier hat man eine OneDrive-History. Guckt mal.
Hier.
Deleted from Desktop. Ja, schön.
Ich würde es gerne wieder restoren. Und jetzt?
Hier, Recycle bin.
Ach ne, ich muss mich noch einloggen.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen bin ich nur unter Windows eingeloggt
und nicht hier. Ja, ist klar.
Ich will nichts kaufen, Mann.
Lass mich hier los.
Okay, das hat jetzt funktioniert.
Okay.
Und jetzt kann ich es restoren.
Und wo ist es?
Da ist es!
Okay, Leute. Wenn man es weiß,
ist es glaube ich
gar nicht so wild.
Aber es ist schon abartig eklig gemacht.
Alles, oder?
Es ist schon abartig eklig.
Also, ganz ehrlich.
Da backup ich lieber,
indem ich regelmäßig
die wichtigsten Sachen
rüberkopieren lasse.
Auf meinen File-Server und dort dann auf
der Platte und
dann einmal nachts auf externe Platte.
How to enable?
Okay.
Enable Copilot
on Windows 11 Preview.
Open GitHub site.
Moment, was?
Moment, was soll ich installieren?
Das Vive-Tool?
What?
Ne.
Das installiere ich mir bestimmt nicht.
Vive-Tool.
C-Sharp Library and console app for using
new feature control.
Ach, das!
Okay, das ist okay.
Das kann man sich runterladen.
Damit kann man quasi interne
Windows-Sachen aktivieren.
Soll ich?
Komm, wir machen das jetzt.
Ich meine, das ist eine VM.
Das können wir schon machen.
Was soll ich runterladen?
Einfach hier das neueste Zipper.
Äh.
Download ist einfach lahm.
Newton Soft Jason.
Bester Dude.
Und nu? Ach, das synkt ja dann auch in die Cloud.
Okay, das ist ziemlich doof.
Wie benutzt man das jetzt?
Vive-Tool enable.
Was muss man hier nochmal?
Alter!
Desktop.
Describe CD Desktop.
Desk.
Hallo? Desk?
Wo ist mein Desktop-Ordner?
OneDrive schon wieder?
Jetzt ist das so...
Die wollen mich doch komplett verarschen, oder?
Und jetzt?
Error.
Sudo. Lul.
Oder muss ich das als Admin machen?
Successfully set feature configuration.
Nee, man muss das...
Run as administrator.
Okay, okay, okay.
Terminal.
Es ist auch so dumm, dass es kein Sudo gibt unter Windows.
Hallo?
Nee.
Das geht ja nicht.
Darf man nicht reintracken und droppen, ja.
One.
OneDrive Desktop.
Ist einfach so krass hängen geblieben.
So.
Jetzt aber.
Vive-Tool.
Okay, successfully enabled.
Restart Computer.
Reboot.
Nee, Windows.
Shutdown.
Minus R ist es, glaube ich.
Minus R.
Minus N für Now.
Hm.
Minus T, Null.
Restart Windows.
Ich meine,
wenn Rebooten auf der Command-Line schon abfuck ist,
was soll man dazu sagen?
Start Process.
Das ist die .NET.
Klingt sehr nach .NET.
Start Process.
Restart minus Compute.
Ach, guck mal, da ist es.
Ich höre nicht mehr.
Da ist es, guck mal.
Copilot Preview.
Es lädt.
Okay, ask me anything.
Okay.
Who has
the most chat messages
on the
Wobloss Twitch
Channel? Das kann es nicht wissen.
Oh, oh, ich glaube es ist
Wobloss himself.
Ähm.
Laut der Statistik wahrscheinlich
schon. Gar nicht mal
schlecht. Gar nicht, gar nicht mal
schlecht. Aber.
Ah, okay, und
Tom47Exact,
den kenne ich natürlich. Der hat
sicherlich schon sehr viele Messages geschrieben.
Es halluziniert, würde ich sagen.
Can you enable
light mode?
Mode.
Auch sehr gut gemacht, dass das da oben drüber
overlaid.
Nicht schlecht, das ist ganz nützlich.
Wobei man auch einfach hier
dark theme und so suchen könnte,
aber okay. Okay, nice.
I know I prefer dark mode.
Und jetzt?
Jetzt haben wir es kaputt gemacht.
Ah, jetzt, okay.
Ähm.
Install Git.
Oh, Leute, wir sind zu schnell.
Wir sind zu schnell.
Searching how to install Git on Windows.
Kannst du chat?
Stimmt, der Chat ist davor. Okay, Moment, Moment.
Ja, das verschieben wir.
Ich mach euch mal kurz hier oben hin.
Aber jetzt ist immer noch Chico drüber, ne?
Okay.
Install Notepad++
with WinGit.
Also das ist schon mal PQIDesign,
dass das immer da drüber erscheint.
Okay, das kann es nicht.
Das kann es nicht, WinGit benutzen.
To install with WinGit
you need to have
WinGit command line tool installed.
Jaja, weiß ich.
WinGit install Notepad++
Notepad++
Ich will aber Notepad++ gar nicht installieren,
weil Notepad++
naja,
irgendwie nicht mehr zeitgemäß, finde ich.
Kann man gleich via Code installieren.
Download via Code
to download
folder.
Oder soll ich mal fragen, can you, dass er das
checkt.
Can you download
via Code into download
folder.
Naja, nervt nicht rum.
Please install
via Code for me.
Kannst du nur 30 Fragen stellen?
Nö, warum?
Achso, hier, ja, tatsächlich.
Dann? Weiß ich nicht.
Das sind wahrscheinlich die so und so viele Antworten oder so.
Okay, das kann er nicht.
Er kann nichts installieren.
Okay, das ist auch schon mal
nicht schlecht. Cool, dass das funktioniert.
Lass mal ausprobieren, ob das tut.
Terminal
zack.
Das ist doch gar nicht mal
so übel, oder?
Ist doch ganz okay.
Die Desktop-Icons sind
verkackt.
Sie gehen immer kaputt.
What can
you do for me?
Fragen wir mal.
Was das Ding eigentlich kann.
So richtig den Sinn
davon verstehe ich noch nicht.
I can do many things.
Ja, das kann ich selbst.
Create graphical artwork.
Wow, wollen wir
das mal ausprobieren?
Okay, ich weiß.
Ich weiß, was wir machen.
Create a logo
for my program
for MChamp.
It is used
to manage Linux
virtual machines.
Mal ein
Pepo. Das ist auch gut.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Das ist ein bisschen zu detailreich
für ein Logo, oder?
Moment, was zum?
Alles klar.
Alles klar, okay.
Ich meine,
das hier ist irgendwie ganz cool.
Da könnte man schon was mit anfangen.
Draw
a Pepo for me.
Bester Name.
Oh, jetzt haben wir
glaube ich Paint.
Ja, haben wir schon ausprobiert.
Ich erkenne da jetzt gar nicht so viel Unterschied in Paint.
Was ist da jetzt so viel anders?
Das ist kein Pepo.
That is not
a Pepo.
I mean Pepe the Frog.
Nicht searching.
Okay, oh, I'm sorry.
Ich weiß,
aber okay.
Nun ja.
Okay, jetzt kriege ich ein Bild.
Naja, so
nicht wirklich, aber okay.
Yep, yep, clock.
Draw Twitch Chat?
Moment, ich frage einfach mal
Draw Twitch Chat. Was kommt da raus
wohl?
Das ergibt nicht wirklich Sinn.
Wir fragen mal.
Das frage ich ihn mal.
Das ist Twitch Chat.
Okay.
Leaked,
Leute.
Okay, jetzt weiß ich endlich.
Oh, cursed.
Cursed Gesichtsausdrücke.
Das ist Twitch Chat.
Ich bin froh, dass es euch
jetzt, jetzt könnt ihr euch nicht mal verstecken.
Okay.
How
does
looks like
MaxFPS face reveal.
Is a
German YouTube and
Twitch streamer who mainly focus on
IT, gaming and comment.
Das ist gar nicht mal so falsch.
Was?
He is not
for his own information.
Other streamers like
Technikkeller und
Axxosa. Ich weiß gar nicht,
wer ist?
Okay, Moment.
Wer ist Axxosa?
Ein Minecraft
Let's Player?
Ein italienischer
oder so Minecraft Let's Player?
Ein Spanischer.
Ja, mit dem
habe ich natürlich schon oft kooperiert.
Where does
live
Kong? Hast du eigentlich auch
dieses YouTube Trophäe? Du meinst den silbernen
Button? Ja, den habe ich auch.
However, none of them directly answer
answers.
Sie wissen es nicht.
Ask him personally. Good luck.
Ja,
ich finde die Integration gar nicht
so verkehrt. Ich meine,
da hat man Chat-GPT auf
dem Desktop und kann was fragen.
Ich meine, ein bisschen Spielerei ist es,
aber vielleicht so für
ich habe mal gar keine Idee.
Kannst du
Deutsch?
Max FPS
Logo. Ansonsten war es das
glaube ich mit den Neuerungen
in Windows 11
23 H2.
Wir haben uns
alles angeguckt. Ich brauche
nichts davon. Schon gar nicht diese
komische OneNote Backup-Integration.
Einzige, was ich extrem
nice finde, was ja aus
irgendwelchen Gründen entfernt wurde, ist das
Kopieren von Icons
in der
Task-Leiste.
E4-Zoom-Boxes.
Exzellenter Text.
Oder
Max
Nun ja, so sieht es aus.
Was macht dieses komische Menü?
Hierneben gibt es immer noch
Tryout-Meeting-Backgrounds.
Ja, unbedingt. Da muss ich jetzt sein.
Blum, blum, blum, blum.
Wup, wup, wup,
wup, wup, wup, wup.
Okay Leute, wollen wir noch ein, zwei
Videos gucken? Irgendwas ein bisschen IT-bezogenes?
Weil, wir
haben alle neue Funktionen ausprobiert. Es sei denn,
ihr wollt noch irgendwas Spezielles sehen?
Gibt ja sonst nichts mehr. Also,
das waren die Neuerungen.
Wenn ihr noch was sehen wollt,
dann sagt schnell,
weil ich werde die vor allem jetzt gleich löschen.
Wir können uns mal angucken, was wir uns anschauen.
Was haben wir denn hier noch?
Es war doch irgendein Video, wurde dir
empfohlen. Fachinformatiker-Ausbildung
bei Hermes.
Das wollte ich doch die ganze Zeit schon
mir anschauen, was Hermes
so
für die Physi-Ausbildung macht. Wo ist das denn?
Ja, Hermes.
Physi-Ausbildung bei
Hermes. Mal gucken.
Wurde BUN schon thematisiert?
Ja, mehrfach.
Was willst du wissen?
Bum.
Big Shuck.
Die könnte ich eigentlich auch mal löschen,
die Proxmox-Dinger.
Virtual Machines
Windows 11.
Zack. Delete.
Bam.
Nichts? Okay.
Seit wann
übersetzt YouTube die Titel so
komisch?
IT-Specialist in Application Development
and System Integration.
Der Titel von dem Video ist eigentlich
Fachinformatiker-Anwendungsentwicklung
bei Hermes oder sowas.
Irgendwie
Multi
Translation.
Wann arbeitest du wieder an einem
Swell-Projekt, wenn ich irgendwie mal fühle, ich
hab die geistige Kapazität
so
mich ordentlich zu konzentrieren?
So, Chico muss wieder rein
und der Chad, der muss auch
wieder rein. So heißt der Beruf.
Die Fachrichtung macht den Unterschied.
Also gucken wir mal,
was es ist, wenn man bei Hermes
eine Phi-AE-Ausbildung bzw. eine
Physie-Ausbildung macht.
Anwendungsentwicklung oder Systemintegration.
Was ist das genau?
Hallo, mein Name ist Sebastian Jurocek, ich bin 27 Jahre alt.
Ich bin Auszubildender Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration.
Und wie alt ist der?
Ich glaube,
der ist fast so alt,
ungefähr das Alter, als ich meine Ausbildung
gemacht hab.
Hallo, mein Name ist Sebastian Jurocek, ich bin 27 Jahre alt.
Naja, nee,
ich war, glaube ich, ein bisschen jünger.
Ich war
QuickMaths
war ich.
Okay.
Hallo, ich bin Jenny,
21 Jahre alt, mache eine Ausbildung
für Fachinformatik und Anwendungsentwicklung.
Ich hoffe,
ich hoffe, Hermes macht nicht ultra-cringiges
Video.
Und das kann sehr anspruchsvoll sein.
Hallo. Jenny.
Oh nein.
Gestellte Szene mit dem Chef für das
Promo-Video.
Grüß dich. Komm her. Geht's dir gut?
Ja. Nimm mal Platz.
Ich hab hier grad ein ganz dringendes Thema.
Genau, und deswegen bestellst
du den Azubi ein, weil
das ein ganz super dringendes Thema ist.
Das kann nur der Azubi erledigen.
Ich mein, vielleicht ist es ja auch wirklich so.
Du sprichst dann aber nicht für die IT-Abteilung.
Es ist wirklich
eine richtig Dice-of-Cringe-Situation jetzt.
Abteilung auf den Helpdesk, wie du weißt.
Und die haben eine ganz große
Kerngeschichte, die sie eigentlich immer bearbeiten.
Ist das ernst?
Ist das wirklich so, Chad?
Ich hab es kurz getestet. Die neue Galerie
im Explorer kann tatsächlich nur
JPG und keine PNGs.
Alter, das ist so schlecht.
Du fragst dich ernsthaft, ob das ein professionelles
Softwareentwicklungsladen ist, was die da
zusammen fabrizieren für ein Schrott.
Sollen sie einfach FFmpeg nehmen?
FFmpeg kann nahezu jedes Video-
und Bildformat.
Okay, also was soll Jenny jetzt machen für ihn, Chef?
Und die haben eine ganz
große Kerngeschichte, die sie eigentlich
immer bearbeiten, und das sind die dir
auch bekannten Beschaffungsanträge.
Das klingt nach
abartig
sinnloser Bürokratie.
Nachbauen in einem Web-
Interface, was sie jetzt machen soll.
Lotus? Moment.
Novell? Moment, was bin
ich da sehend? Wait a minute.
Novell?
Notes Client?
Oh nein,
please, Hermes.
Hermes.
No! No, god, please,
no! No! Also,
okay,
wir haben hier IT von
1995 bis
2008 versammelt.
Anlage vergleichbarer
Mitarbeiter ist auch immer sehr gefährlich,
weil einfach über Jahre hinweg
Rechte, das sollte man auf gar keinen Fall
machen, ich kann das an der Stelle jetzt nochmal sagen,
man sollte auf gar keinen Fall Anlage des
Accounts analog vergleichbarer Mitarbeiter
machen. Da sammeln sich nämlich einfach
über Jahrzehnte teilweise Rechte an.
Niemand weiß mehr, wofür sie
da sind und was sie eigentlich bedeuten.
Und am Ende gibt es
Gruppen,
dadurch, dass die Mitarbeiter haben, die vielleicht schon
rumgekommen sind und lange dabei waren
und die haben Berechtigung
geerbt, die können auf das halbe Unternehmen zugreifen,
obwohl sie es nicht sollten.
Also da würde ich, da wäre ich das,
das finde ich sehr kritisch, ja.
Tracks Tool, Tracks Tool ist top.
Da ist Notes zu Recht vorne
immer.
Das ist so eine Art ausgedrucktes Tickets System,
ja. Ich hab so
Divisionen dabei, dass wir ein System
auf einer Webschnittstelle hätten.
Also was Interaktives dann, dass nur das
kommt, was dann wirklich wichtig ist.
Cringe-gestelltes Gespräch,
Alter.
Darauf ergeben sich jetzt natürlich gewisse
Anforderungen. Dazu gehören dann
Delegieren und neuen Antrag erstellen.
Genehmigen, ablehnen.
Haben die kein System fertig,
wo es, okay, es ist ja bestimmt
eine coole Übung für ein Azubi,
aber ihr habt doch ein fertiges System für sowas.
Warum braucht die ein eigenes,
ja gut, was auch immer.
Man muss nicht vergessen, das ist ein Promofilm
für Hermes.
Und wer kümmert sich um die Hardware?
Ich würde das entsprechend bei der YouTube einkippen und das
entsprechend alles autorisieren.
Eine eigene Kiste
für eine Webanwendung, die irgendwie
drei Leute benutzen dann.
Die wollen es aber wissen.
Ein klarer Auftrag
für Jenny. Ich wollte es aber echt wissen.
Anwendung entwickeln heißt
nicht nur vor dem PC sitzen, sondern auch
dein Programm zu verkaufen, in Meetings zu gehen
und zu kommunizieren.
Jenny entwickelt also Software oder passt sie an?
Sebastian hat mehr mit der Hardware zu tun.
Aufbau, Betrieb und Service.
Sebastian, kommst du mal bitte?
Ja. Herr Rickert hat mich eben angerufen.
Geht um eine Serveraufsetzung. Details weiß ich selbst noch nicht.
Das
schmerzt so.
Ich setze mich bitte mit Jenny in Verbindung.
Besser als ServiceNow.
Hey, was hast du gegen ServiceNow?
Ich musste mir das auch
in der Firma schon geben.
Wir haben auch eine ServiceNow-Installation.
Ja, mir gefällt es auch nicht.
Das ist wirklich
übelst umständlich.
Und vor allem kannst du teilweise nicht Backbutton drücken
im Browser.
Stimmt, die heißen bestimmt nicht mal
IT-Abteilung, sondern EDV-Abteilung.
Aber jetzt mal unabhängig davon.
Auch wenn ich jetzt den Film über ein bisschen läster.
Das kann durchaus eine richtig gute
Ausbildung sein und es ist einfach
ein bisschen unglücklich dargestellt.
Sie wollten es als irgendwie
cool und professionell gleichzeitig
darstellen.
Habt ihr eine Empfehlung für ein Ticketsystem?
Ich finde Jira
gar nicht übel. Ehrlich.
Du kannst Jira
zwar übelst verkonfigurieren
und mit sich Plugins, aber
im Kern, finde ich, ist Jira eigentlich
das angenehmste noch, weil
irgendwie kennt jeder Jira
und in der Default-Ausstattung ist es auch
okay.
Er soll jetzt einen Server bauen.
Eine Server-Aufsetzung.
Oh, das ist so krass gestellt alles.
Das schmerzt.
Was hat er da unten am
Bildschirmpappen?
Hast du
Hast er da irgendwelche Anime-Girls
unten am Bildschirm?
Kann das sein?
Wäre das möglich?
Warum nicht?
Die Waifu-Post-Its.
Was er da benutzt,
das sieht ganz stark nach
Notepad++ aus,
oder? Auch vom Logo her.
Es ist Windows 7
und es machen sie halt ein
Spring-Tutorial auf. Okay, warum
nicht?
Als Mentor kümmert man sich
hauptsächlich darum, dass die Azubis
weiterkommen in ihrer Ausbildung, dass sie
einen Ansprechpartner für ihre Fragen haben
und dass man auch selber mal auf die Azubis
zugeht und schaut, wen sie
Telefone straight aus dem Mittel, alter.
Aber ich mochte diese Dinger,
diese Klötze.
Ja, bitte noch mal
reinzoomen.
Beide Fachrichtungen arbeiten sehr eng zusammen.
Klar, Hardware braucht Software
und umgekehrt.
Guck mal, Jenny hat
ein viel moderneres Telefon
als, äh, Alex.
Nee, äh, wie hieß er?
Ein Tomcat-Server.
Ach so, okay, er fragt
welches Betriebssystem. Okay, dann passt das ja.
Von wann ist das Video?
Ach, guck mal, schon 2 Jahre, aber vor 2 Jahren.
Tomcat.
Ist es nicht so, dass Spring
gar kein Tomcat mehr braucht?
Ich frage als
Nicht-Java-
Kenner. Ich dachte,
du brauchst gar kein Tomcat mehr,
wenn man Spring verwendet.
Äh, Linux.
Okay, wunderbar.
Wenigstens die richtige OS-Entscheidung
am Start.
Können die vielleicht den Leuten
nicht bis auf die Nase zoomen?
Ins Ernst?
Woran habe ich da gerade
deutsche Variablen gesehen?
Nee.
Ach nee, Variablen.
Okay, Variablen.
Was?
PHP und Java?
Moment, stimmt, stimmt.
Gucken, was es für eine Idee ist.
Fuck.
Oh, das Colorscheme,
Leute, sieht ganz hart nach Eclipse aus.
MonkaW.
Das ist,
sag doch mal, Farbschema sieht sehr nach
Default-Eclipse-Colorscheme aus.
Könnte auch Notepad++ sein,
benutze ich nicht, aber
es sieht sehr nach Eclipse aus.
... zwischen PHP und Java,
da Java aber die Haussprache ist,
habe ich mich dafür entschieden.
Das ist die Grundlage,
das sind die ganzen Projektanforderungen,
und ein Klassendiagramm.
Programmieren wird eigentlich nicht direkt
in der Entwicklungsumgebung statt,
sondern eigentlich mehr im Kopf.
Nicht nur einfach APT setzen und ein paar Zeilen
und reinzuschreiben,
sondern auch sich vorher einen Plan zu machen,
was man da eigentlich schreiben möchte.
Ja, das stimmt, Bro.
... ganz so einfach ist es nicht.
Systemintegratoren sind keine reinen Schrauber.
Informatiker sind extrem gefragt.
Ohne sie geht in einem modernen Unternehmen
nichts.
Jetzt kann sich aber jeden
scheiß lustig machen, Chat.
Sebastian, brauchst du da Hilfe?
Systemintegratoren planen und bauen
die Systeme, die die Anwendungsentwickler
für ihre Software brauchen.
Die bauen doch nicht ernsthaft
einen neuen Server ein,
für irgendeine publische Web-Anwendung, oder?
Was ist da los?
Sebastian benutzt Software,
aber er programmiert sie nicht.
Das war die Hardware, jetzt kommt die Software.
Warum nicht?
Also, ich mein,
wait a minute, die installieren von CDs
noch im Rechenzentrum?
Alter, wo bin ich denn hier gelandet?
Also,
Leute, Leute, okay,
ich, also,
ich war schon ewig nicht mehr
im Rechenzentrum,
und selbst als ich im Rechenzentrum war,
noch öfters,
haben wir schon dort nichts mehr von CD
per USB-Stick installiert.
Nee, das Video ist zwei Jahre alt.
Nein, das ist,
das ist von
2021,
August, das ist genau ein zwei Jahre altes Video.
Was steht denn da drauf?
Moment, Moment,
das ist doch uralt, oder?
Wobei, nee,
Sid ist die Testversion immer.
Wait a minute, von wann ist das Video, bitte schön?
Wenn das von 2014 ist,
dann ergibt das auch
alles irgendwie Sinn.
Aber,
aber warum haben,
hä?
Ja, das ist, guckt mal,
guckt euch das Notebook an,
das ist definitiv älter als 2021.
Deswegen haben die auch alle noch Windows 7
und alte Thinkpads und sowas.
Jetzt,
jetzt macht es auch Sinn.
Jetzt, jetzt macht es auch Sinn,
aber warum laden die das jetzt
erst hoch?
Oh nein, oh nein,
ich ahne schon,
cringe-gestelltes Mittagessen kommt jetzt.
Ja,
2014 war es mit CD
zu installieren auch schon out,
aber das ist ja mal was anderes,
als wenn es von 2021 wäre.
Gutes ITler-Essen,
Currywurst mit Pommes frites.
Ganz ehrlich, da hätte ich jetzt auch Bock drauf.
Jenny, du hast ein neues Projekt,
hab ich gehört.
Was hast du da genau?
Ich entwickle ein Programm,
Oh, das ist so cringe-gestellt, Alter.
Ich kann da nicht zugucken.
Ich mache das Projekt alleine.
Die Planung und das Programmieren
mache ich alles alleine.
Wenn ich Fragen habe, kann ich mich fragen.
Eingerichtet hat mir das alles Sebastian.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie unsere Kantine.
Mit dem Server und so, weil
das ist halt nicht so meine Aufgabe.
Zurück in Sebastians Büro.
Während der Mittagspause über
dienstliches Reden ist tabu. Warum?
Mach ich auch.
Ich hab mit den meisten Leuten sonst,
außer das Dienstliche, nicht viel Schnittmenge.
Da war ein Kalender. Moment, wo?
Wo? Wo?
Da! Da!
Ja, aber das erkennt man leider nicht.
Es ist zu,
es ist zu pixellig.
Man sieht es nicht.
Wenigstens geht das Remote.
Ja, guckt euch die Monitore an.
Das sind alte 4 zu 3
Monitore.
Das ist auf jeden Fall älter, Leute.
Das ist nicht von 2021.
Die haben das einfach
jetzt erst hochgeladen.
Und ganz ehrlich,
die Kameraaufnahmen sehen auch ein bisschen aus,
als wäre das mal ein Interlaced-Video.
Das sieht man hier zum Beispiel daran,
dass es ein bisschen
Guckt euch mal hier oben
an den Konturen das an.
Das könnte durchaus mal
ein Interlaced-Video gewesen sein,
ursprünglich.
Niemand muss klicken,
damit er unter...
Ne, egal.
Das hat er für den Shore-Effekt gemacht.
Was haben wir da drüben?
Irgend ein Olnagios noch, oder?
Ist das noch...
Ich erkenne es nicht so genau.
Ne, oder?
Ist was anderes.
Sieht aber oldschoolig aus.
Altes PRTG.
Ja, das ist ein Firefox
von 2014, Leute.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum die das jetzt
erst hochgeladen haben.
Sebastian?
Ihr seid doch morgen in Hannover, ne?
Könntest du bitte nochmal drauf achten,
dass ihr euch ganz besonders die Tore 13 bis 28
anguckt? 13 bis 28, na klar.
Langenhagen bei Hannover.
Hier ist eine der fünf riesigen Verteilerstationen.
Hubs genannt.
Hier wird alles mit Hilfe von Rechnern gesteuert.
Sebastian soll mit den Kollegen Fehlerquellen finden
und abschalten.
Inwieweit genau
kann ein Physi ihm da helfen,
wenn das Verteilerband
nicht richtig geht?
Millionen Pakete werden erfasst,
transportiert und auf ihrem Weg kontrolliert.
Jede Sendung ist ein Vorgang, der nur ein Ziel kennt.
Einen zufriedenen Empfänger.
Jenny hat einen anderen Brocken vor sich.
Sie muss ihr Programm vor großer Runde vorstellen.
Schönen guten Tag.
Danke, dass Sie sich Zeit genommen haben.
Mein Name ist Jenny Goldbach.
Ey Leute, das ist 100 Pro,
so eine Präsentation, wo irgendjemand
zu Jenny gesagt hat, weißt du was?
Und wenn das Programm fertig ist,
dann stellst du das mal in größerer Runde vor.
So, das muss man auch mal lernen.
Jenny kein Bock drauf,
die Zuhörer kein Bock drauf
und am Ende braucht das Programm wahrscheinlich
auch nicht mal jemand.
Das ist so ein typisches Ding,
wo einfach nur gemacht wird, um es zu machen.
Die sehen auch alle schon so aus,
als haben sie wahnsinnig Bock da drauf.
Und vor allem,
warum ist Jan, ich hab den Namen vergessen,
da dabei?
Der muss doch gar nicht benutzen.
Die haben da alle keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist alles so fake.
So fake
Aufmerksamkeit.
So, ja okay, dann gucken wir.
Und am Ende sagen wir eine ganz tolle Präsentation
und
Ich meine, es ist nicht verkehrt.
Ja.
Wenn man das ab und zu mal ein bisschen üben kann,
ist schon okay.
Aber die haben einen riesen Raum sich rausgesucht.
Ist es denn ausschließlich
ein Azubi Projekt oder hat es wirklich
richtige Auswirkungen auf das komplette Unternehmen?
Da müsstest du eigentlich sagen,
frag meinen Chef, der das haben will.
Also es ist vorgesehen, dass dieses Programm
auch in Zukunft produktiv bei Hermes
eingesetzt werden soll.
Ich will Ihnen jetzt mal die Aufgaben vorstellen,
die Funktionen dieses Programm hat und wie es nachher eingesetzt werden soll.
Es gibt ein Problem.
Oh.
Hi Ben, Sebastian hier.
Ich bin jetzt hier am Nordabend nach Hannover.
Hab ich dir doch gestern gesagt.
Alter, Alter, was für eine ultra
passiv-aggressive Antwort.
Sag mal, kannst du mir noch mal erzählen,
was für ein Tor?
Das hab ich dir doch gestern gesagt.
23 bis 25, Alter.
Sag mal, welche Tore waren denn das nochmal?
Ich bin jetzt hier am Nordabend nach Hannover.
Hab ich dir doch gestern gesagt.
13 bis 28.
Gut,
das ist einfach nur gestellt dafür.
Das ist halt nicht so.
Direkt Abwarnung rausgeschickt.
156 bis
131.
Das Programm ist über das Internet aufrufbar.
Dort können Sie neue Anträge stellen,
diese verwalten, nochmal nachschauen,
bearbeiten, genehmigen lassen, ablehnen lassen.
Also quasi
das, was man mit einem Ticketsystem macht.
Ist lang, ausführlich und sehr anstrengend.
Bei welchen Toren gibt es die meisten Probleme?
Sebastian lässt sich die Probleme
mit der Torsteuerung genau erklären.
Ich bedanke mich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben, stellen Sie die jetzt gerne.
Ihren Vortrag hat Jenny gut abgeliefert.
Ihr kennt mich,
ihr wisst, dass ich den Spruch zum Schluss
nicht mag.
Softwareentwicklung findet eben nicht nur
am Rechner.
Und wer hat eigentlich dieses auf den Tisch klopfen
erfunden?
Ich weiß, das kommt irgendwie aus der Uni
oder so. Aber warum klopfen die immer auf den Tisch?
Können die nicht einfach klatschen?
Oder noch besser?
Einfach irgendwie
etwas Nettes sagen?
So, oh ja, das ist ein Tool,
was uns wahrscheinlich echt das Leben erleichtert.
Keine Ahnung.
Dings hier, Jan ist weg.
Der hat keinen Bock mehr gehabt.
Das war meine erste große Präsentation.
War ganz schön anstrengend.
Ich war ganz schön aufgeregt.
Aber es gehört eben dazu.
Man muss ein Projekt ja auch verkaufen können.
Das stimmt.
Wobei man halt sagen muss,
je nachdem ist es nicht unbedingt
der einzelne Entwickler,
der ein Projekt verkaufen muss.
Da hängt ja noch viel mehr dran.
Aber prinzipiell, ja.
Man muss nicht unbedingt das Projekt
verkaufen können, man muss sich halt
halbwegs verkaufen können.
Man muss irgendwie seine Skills
gut bewerben auch.
Also wenn man was Gescheites gemacht hat,
ist es besser, anstatt das nächste
Gescheite zu machen, erstmal ein bisschen
drüber zu reden, was man eben
gemacht hat.
Stimmt, das war 2014.
Da haben sie noch nicht Agile Diagonal skaliert
mit Daily Scrum. Da ging das alles
noch nicht.
Da waren sie auch noch nicht safe, lean und T-Shaped.
Irgendwelche Ausfälle oder ähnliches.
Das sind eigentlich alle vierundviertel Stunden
im Betrieb. Ich kann natürlich auch mal kurz gucken gehen
und da testen, ob das irgendwie von hier aus
zu machen ist.
Sebastians Aufgabe zeigt gut, wie weit
IT in die Unternehmen vorgedrungen ist.
Interessant, dass ein Physi an der Torsteuerung
und so rummachen muss, das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Hier ist jedes Tor mit einem Rechner
verbunden und wird bundesweit zentral...
Oh nice, mit VGA anschließend.
Aber gut, 2014, ja.
...gesteuert.
...von hier aus.
Es ist natürlich so, wie gesagt, ich schreibe es
wieder mit auf, gebe es wieder weiter an die Kollegen.
Ich hoffe mal, dass die für euch dann die
Software fertig machen, damit ihr das dann einfach
von hier aus steuern könnt,
einrichten könnt, damit das dann wieder läuft.
Ob Anwendungsentwickler
oder Systemintegrator, nur
am Rechner hocken, ist für keinen mehr drin.
Das hat sich tatsächlich
die letzten Jahre über geändert.
Ich fand die Zeit, wo ich
Was zum Teufel
bin ich denn hier gelandet?
24 Stunden als
Fachinformatiker.
Daily life
auf Physi-Zubi.
Gibt es da Kommentare? Meinst du bei Hermes?
Ja, lass uns mal kurz gucken.
Da nur 6 Comments.
Keine Ahnung.
Was ist ein
Physi? Ein Fachinformatiker Systemintegration.
Da schreibt man es auch mit F vorne.
Also Fachinformatiker
fangen die ganzen Berufe an und danach gibt es dann
sowas wie
Daten- und Prozessanalyse
glaube ich heißt das. Das sind die Neuen.
Die Neuen für
digitale Vernetzung oder sowas.
Es sind auch die anderen Neuen und
dann die Klassiker Systemintegration
und Anwendungsentwicklung.
Oder ich glaube, so heißen die zwei Neuen doch.
Was ist das hier?
24 Stunden
als Fachinformatiker verbringen.
Ich vermute mal.
Er zeigt uns seinen Arbeitsplatz, oder?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
High Heels, Shorts.
Das geht
noch. Ich glaube, das habe ich offen, weil ich
das mir irgendwo empfohlen. Wir gucken ja öfters
mal so Azubi-Videos.
Da kriegt man sowas auch mal empfohlen.
Mein Tag als
Softwareentwickler.
Klingt super begeistert.
Okay.
TikTok-Video vorbei.
What the fuck?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich mir das weiter
angucken möchte.
Vielleicht ist das auch irgendein Troll-Video.
Okay. Das war
einfach nur Intro für die TikTok-Generation.
Ich weiß, cooler Hintergrund.
Das hat keiner gesehen.
Dice of
Cringe, Alter.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ich möchte auch gar nicht so viel labern, deswegen nehme ich euch auch schon mal mit zu meinem Arbeitsplatz.
Auf geht's.
Mein Tag fängt meistens um 8 Uhr an.
Was mache ich als erstes? Ich fahre erstmal
alles hoch, wie zum Beispiel einen Rechner.
Das ist natürlich eine gute Idee,
seinen Notebook erstmal einzuschalten.
Wie zum Beispiel den Rechner.
Dann öffne ich zum Beispiel unser Ticketsystem.
Wo ist das Ticketsystem?
Öffne ich zum Beispiel...
Das sieht eher nach dem Osi-Modell aus.
Das ist nicht das
Ticketsystem.
Ich weiß, ich habe
gerade nur Google aufgemacht, aber das sind
Firmeninterne Daten und es geht ja nur darum,
dass ich euch zeige. Also nur zum Verständnis.
Nicht, dass ihr gleich anfängt zu kommentieren.
Das geht ja nicht.
Dann will ich erstmal Wasser auffüllen,
um irgendwie wach zu werden, weil wie gesagt,
es ist etwas früh. Ihr merkt, ich habe einen leichten
Knacks, aber ist okay.
Ist nicht schlimm. Ja, nachdem ich diese
Sachen gemacht habe, ist es auch sehr wichtig für mich,
dass ich den Tag plane.
Deswegen rufe ich auch erstmal alles auf.
Also das Ticketsystem, Outlook und so weiter.
Und plane erstmal so meinen Tag.
Er macht Kalender Bayern, anstatt Outlook aufzumachen.
Aber okay, er kann es nicht zeigen,
gette ich.
Das Video ist neu, ja.
Ein bisschen vorbereiten auf den Tag und ich
direkt ins kalte Wasser. Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Ja.
Was für Handbewegungen.
Oh Gott, was ist das?
Alter.
Den Tag und ich direkt ins kalte Wasser.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Was für Handbewegungen.
Der Typ, Alter.
Es ist jetzt 9 Uhr und wir haben ein Teammeeting.
Was macht man in einem Teammeeting?
Eigentlich sind hier noch Leute, aber ich habe
keine Freunde, deswegen kann ich euch das nicht zeigen.
Das ist doch irgendein Troll-Video, oder?
Ich meine da Themen,
was heute der Plan ist, was man
so zu tun hat. Wichtige Themen, die man
vielleicht als Team auch besprechen sollte.
Ich glaube, da wäre ein perfekter Influencer
aus Dubai oder so.
Der kommt bestimmt noch
in Zukunft.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Video ernst gemeint ist, keine Ahnung.
Ich hoffe, dass ich das lösen kann.
Das sieht ungefähr so aus.
IT ist ...
Later.
Ich habe vergessen, was ich hinschreiben wollte.
Hier werden Themen besprochen.
Komplexere Themen.
Themen, wo ihr denkt, der ist krass.
Das verstehe ich nicht mehr.
IT ist ...
krass.
Was, Bruder?
Ja.
Genau so sieht das aus.
Eine halbe Stunde, kommt drauf an.
Manchmal länger, manchmal weniger.
Das kommt auf den Tag an.
Mir fällt es wirklich schwer, das weiterzukommen.
So wie ich euch
meinen Tag erzähle, erzähle ich ihn
auch im Team-Meeting mit den anderen.
Oh, ein Anruf.
Wie spontan.
Hayal aus der IT,
was kann ich für Sie tun?
Typischer Support-Anruf.
Der Scheiß funktioniert nicht.
Ich schalte mich mal auf Landrechner.
Ich kann Ihren PC leider nicht erreichen.
Das war tatsächlich ein guter Joke.
Ja, ich schalte mich mal auf Landrechner.
Den fand ich jetzt
besser als die anderen.
Ich kann Ihren PC leider
nicht erreichen.
Es scheint, als hätten Sie ein Netzwerkproblem.
Sind Sie mit dem WLAN verbunden?
Arbeiten Sie im Homeoffice?
Seit wann tritt das Problem auf?
Alles kacke.
Sie haben auch schon ein Ticket dazu erstellt?
Dann melde ich mich noch mal.
Ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen wunderschönen Tag.
Ebenso.
Nach dem Team-Meeting
kommen auch schon die ersten Anrufe.
Meistens schon ab 8 Uhr.
Aber die meisten rufen nach dem Team-Meeting erst an.
Das ist dann ca. nach 9.30 Uhr.
Ich würde mal sagen, es gibt immer so 3 Arten,
wenn man telefoniert.
Einmal, das hat sich selbst gelöst.
Ja, die gibt es öfters.
Als Azubi, meine ich jetzt.
Wie z.B. ein Outlook, neues Profil anlegen.
Oder sich mit dem VPN verbinden.
Da kann man gerne helfen.
Und dann gibt es noch die Probleme, die man nicht lösen kann.
Was auch nicht so schlimm ist,
weil meistens schon ein Ticket dafür erstellt wurde.
Das heißt, da stehen auch noch mal Infos.
Das Problem, Leute,
da muss ich mich auch mal dran gewöhnen.
Das ist echt guter Advice.
Das Problem ist nicht so schlimm,
automatisch, wenn bald ein Ticket erstellt wurde.
Also so nach dem Motto,
Rechenzentrum brennt.
Sekunde, ich mache erstmal ein Ticket auf.
Dann ist das Problem nicht mehr so schlimm.
Man kann auch bei seinem Team nachfragen.
Man hat ja auch ein Team, ein IT-Team.
Und unser bester Freund und Helfer, Google.
Das heißt, am Telefon auch einfach
ehrlich sein und nett.
Ich meine, die Leute essen einen keinen auf,
weil die wollen ja Hilfe von uns.
Das stimmt, das vergessen.
Schön Hacker-Typer im Hintergrund.
Das stimmt schon.
Das vergessen nur Anrufe oftmals.
Dass die eigentlich Hilfe haben wollen.
Die tun so,
als hätte derjenige am anderen Ende
es persönlich kaputt gemacht
bei ihnen.
Am Anfang gesehen beim Intro,
das ist unser Überwachungsbildschirm.
Chat, halt euch mal ein bisschen zurück.
PRTG zeigt uns die Fehlermeldungen an.
Zum Beispiel ein Server ist ausgefallen.
Und meistens steht auch noch,
was für ein Fehler.
Ist das PRTG?
Vermutlich, ja.
Windows-Only-Zeug.
Kenn ich nicht.
Das heißt, wir überwachen auch die ganzen Geräte.
Das ist auch eine Aufgabe.
Manchmal kommt es vor...
Ja, jetzt geht das mit dem Video.
Der Anfang war schon ein bisschen heftig cringe.
Guck mal, das sind die alten Lenovo-Mäuse.
Wenn es einmal sehr, sehr stressig wird,
wie jetzt zum Beispiel...
PRTG kann nicht unter Linux laufen.
Eine PRTG-Meldung kommt.
Dann auf einmal richtig viele Anrufe reinkommen.
Das hatten wir auch schon mal.
Dann kommen sehr, sehr viele Anrufe rein,
dass gerade nichts funktioniert.
Das kann auch zu sehr stressigen Situationen kommen.
Deswegen habe ich keinen Bock auf Support.
Bei mir beginnt um 10 die Hochbetriebsphase.
Was das genau ist,
ich habe am Anfang schon mal was erwähnt gehabt
von Tagesplanung.
Wenn ich reinkomme, werfe ich mich selber nicht direkt ins kalte Wasser
und mache die schwierigen Aufgaben,
weil ich einfach noch nicht gescheit wach bin.
Und um 10 ist bei mir wirklich...
Guter Plan.
Deswegen habe ich die schweren Aufgaben,
das Highlight vom Tag,
verschiebe ich dann meistens auf 10 Uhr.
Ich habe 20 Scanner bekommen
und die müsste ich einrichten.
Das heißt für mich jetzt, ich müsste den Scanner installieren,
ich müsste ihn aufbereiten.
Aufbereiten im Sinne von nach Beschädigungen prüfen
oder ob der überhaupt noch gescheit funktioniert,
ob Tasten kaputt sind.
Das ist so eine typische Azubi-Aufgabe.
Irgendjemand hat da keinen Bock drauf
und hat gesagt, haja, mach mal.
Das ist toll,
da lernst du noch was bei.
Und das ist bestimmt nur bei ihm gelandet,
weil irgendein anderer keinen Bock drauf gehabt hat
und hat sich gedacht, das können wir auf ein Azubi abschieben.
Das Scanner-Thema ist jetzt zum Beispiel
speziell mein Thema.
Das hat vielleicht nicht jede Firma so.
Wir haben halt ein Lager, deswegen gibt es bei uns auch die Scanner.
Dafür bin ich so gefühlt zuständig.
Das heißt, bei mir wäre es erstmal ab 10 Uhr
Highlight des Tages, Scanner installieren,
weil ich da doch einige habe.
Und das wäre jetzt so eine große Aufgabe, sage ich mal.
Doch, also, wenn ich mir das jetzt angucke,
der meint das Video ernst.
Das am Anfang war halt einfach nur ein bisschen übertrieben.
Und ich glaube,
da ist echt nicht verkehrt.
Genau.
Erstmal eine Runde Chicken Wings bestellen.
Boah, geil.
5,20 Euro für Nuggets.
Nach der Mittagspause bin ich sehr kaputt.
Das hat auch seinen Grund, ich esse sehr viel.
Deswegen ist für mich um 13 Uhr schon wieder
eine Phase, die nenne ich jetzt mal
entspanntere Phase.
Da mache ich entspanntere Aufgaben, wie zum Beispiel das Bericht.
Ja, manch einer wird auch sagen,
Mittagessen-Koma angesagt
um 13 Uhr.
Ja, ich versuche so gegen 14 Uhr wieder am Start zu sein.
Hier seht ihr zum Beispiel, laufe ich rum.
Aktiv.
Ich laufe jetzt nicht wild durchs Büro die ganze Zeit.
Ich nehme euch jetzt mit, weil es gibt ein Drucker-Problem.
Ja, ich habe vorhin in den Tickets gesehen,
dass es ein Drucker-Problem gibt.
Um mir das Ganze anzuschauen.
Und ich habe sogar auch schon eine Vermutung,
woran es liegen könnte.
Nach drei Jahren hat man schon direkt seine Vermutungen.
Okay, drei Jahre ist er quasi
fast fertig, oder?
Da hat er jetzt Abschlussprüfung.
Eingetragen oder hinterlegt.
Ist der Scan-Einzug vielleicht verstopft?
Oder ist einfach kein Papier drin oder so?
Oder wurde der Drucker nicht eingerechnet?
Genau, da das Papier passt, schauen wir mal oben beim Scan-Einzug.
Das geht hier so auf.
Meistens steckt hier dann hier ein Papierschnipsel
oder sowas fest.
Genau, das ist die Scannerrolle.
Die ist auch sauber.
Ich habe jetzt auf jeden Fall mit ihr noch telefoniert
und die Karte war auf jeden Fall nicht hinterlegt.
Das habe ich dann per Web-Oberfläche vom Drucker-Programm gemacht.
Ja, hat sich erledigt. Ticket schließen.
Hi, hallo.
Ja, grüezi, grazie. Ich muss ein Kabel gepatcht werden.
Bitte sofort runterkommen.
Okay.
Ja, ich komme sofort.
Vor allem, ich muss jetzt runter in den Serverraum.
Ich erkläre euch gleich, was abgeht.
Sofort.
Es ist hier ein bisschen lauter, deswegen muss ich hier lauter reden.
Wie ich euch vorhin bereits mitgeteilt habe,
ich bin jetzt im Serverraum und was machen mich hier?
Ich patche ein Kabel.
Was bedeutet das Ganze?
Das bedeutet das Kabel an der Wand,
das Sound-Kabel eben, das muss man hier patchen,
bis es überhaupt Internet hat.
Ich suche von oben die ...
Im Prinzip wird das wahrscheinlich
nicht groß gepatcht.
Es wird
ein fertiges Kabel genommen,
zum Patch-Panel hochgesteckt,
auf der anderen Seite dran
und dann vorne auf das
jeweilige fürs Telefon oder so.
... die an der Dose stand.
Warum sagt man eigentlich patchen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
... und den verbinde ich dann zum Switch.
Von da aus kommt dann das Internet.
Das hier zum Beispiel ist auch sehr interessant.
Da drinnen sind Festplatten
und sobald man ein Backup macht ...
Ist das etwa eine Tape-Library?
... fährt dieses Teil hier rum,
holt sich das Tape, wo das Backup läuft
und spielt es dann wieder ein,
dass wir es dann wieder restoren können.
Tape-Libraries sind nice. Ohne Scheiß.
Ich habe mal
in einem weiteren Standort
vom letzten Arbeitgeber
musste ich mal, glaube ich,
insgesamt bestimmt 2 Stunden morgens
rumhocken und warten,
bis sich was getan hat.
Und von der Zeit
habe ich jetzt bestimmt
... lass mal nicht übertreiben ...
45 Minuten
nur in die Tape-Library geguckt,
wie die Ärmel da rumfahren und die Bänder rumdingsen.
Das hat irgendwas meditatives.
... wo das Backup läuft
und spielt es dann wieder ein,
dass wir es dann wieder restoren können.
Hier sieht man immer viel Bling-Bling.
Grünes Bling-Bling ist immer gut,
das heißt, es funktioniert.
Orange oder Rot ist nicht gut.
Wahrscheinlich hat man eh schon eine PHTG-Meldung.
Deswegen einfach mal reinschauen.
Freunde, hier müsst ihr auch aufpassen.
Manche Kabel sind sehr empfindlich,
wie die Lichtwellenleiter zum Beispiel.
Das wären in dem Fall die blauen.
Deswegen beim Zumachen einfach schauen,
dass ihr da keine ...
Ah, ich habe gedacht,
deswegen lassen sie die Tür immer auf.
Da war so ein Patch,
einer der Schranke, der war so voll
und auch so unordentlich gepatcht,
dass du die Tür nicht zumachen konntest,
ohne richtig dagegen zu drücken.
Da hat sich keiner mehr getraut, dagegen zu drücken.
Kabel einklemmen beim Zumachen.
Genau.
Ja, Freunde, ich habe euch jetzt ein paar Einblicke geben können.
Es ist jetzt schon so 16 Uhr
und ich fange schon langsam an, den Tag abzuschließen.
Was heißt das für mich?
Offene Tickets verteile ich jetzt
entweder auf morgen oder ich schaue einfach, was ich damit mache.
Ja, zwischendurch kommen jetzt natürlich auch noch andere Aufgaben dazu.
Ich habe euch jetzt mal bei einer mitgenommen.
Zum Beispiel das Testen, ob das dann auch funktioniert hat,
wirklich das Kabel umstecken.
Da ich in dem Zeitraum von 16 bis 17 Uhr
dann auch nach Hause gehe, räume ich eigentlich schon mal
meine Sachen auf und da mache ich meinen Platz
auch noch sauber für morgen.
Ich habe euch hoffentlich jetzt einen groben Einblick geben können
von meinem IT-Alltag.
Natürlich gibt es noch viel, viel, viel, viel mehr.
Das ist tatsächlich sehr klassisches Physi-Zeug hier.
Nichts super Advances,
aber das, was wahrscheinlich
viele Physis
auch gerade in der Ausbildung machen,
so in kleineren Unternehmen,
damit rumgelaufen, mal geguckt,
warum geht das nicht, warum ist der Drucker im Arsch,
warum zieht das Telefon keine IP,
rüber ins Rechenzentrum gehen,
irgendeine Festplatte umstöpseln.
Ja, das ist, also
vieles davon habe ich in der Ausbildung auch damals
gemacht beim Provider, nur dass da halt
noch ein bisschen der Anteil
von Rechenzentrum doch noch höher war
mit dem Server einbauen und allem.
Ja.
Aber ich kann nicht alles zeigen, deswegen ich habe jetzt mal ein paar mitgenommen,
die ich cool fand.
Wenn ihr Fragen habt oder auch Anmerkungen,
ich muss mal kurz gucken, guck mal, das ist ein Jahr alt.
Hat der mittlerweile seine
Abschlussprüfung, er muss ja locker seine Abschlussprüfung
bestanden haben.
Ja, habe ich meine Ausbildung geschafft.
Ich will mal nur kurz durch,
hat er es geschafft?
Egal ob es bei Instagram war, bei TikTok
oder auf YouTube, dass ihr mir Fragen
stellen sollt. Und ich habe 23 Fragen
rausgepickt, die...
Wie sieht es eigentlich bei dir zur Zeit,
willst du in der Ausbildung noch
in der IT bleiben oder gehen im Physia-Zubi?
Was kann ich mir im Zubi...
Ich glaube, ich rede jetzt ein bisschen generell.
Okay, ich glaube, er hat es geschafft.
So, ich bin jetzt fertig mit der Ausbildung.
Ich mache jetzt erstmal nichts.
Die einen nennen es Auslandsjahr,
die anderen...
Einfach erstmal nichts machen, kann ich mich gut damit
identifizieren. Die anderen nennen es einfach, ich mache
ein Jahr Pause, aber in diesem einen Jahr,
das nutze ich jetzt für mich, um Erfahrung zu sammeln,
auch ein bisschen reisen zu gehen und auch...
Ja, kann man ja machen. Okay, also er hat die Ausbildung
geschafft. Das ist auch gut zu hören.
Fragt mich, ob er keinen Bock mehr auf
den Laden hat, ob sie ihn nicht übernommen haben
oder ob der Laden dicht gemacht hat oder so.
Also direkt nach der Ausbildung
erstmal ein Jahr Pause ist schon
nicht, sag mal,
nicht so üblich.
B.o.E. gefunden, instant Arbeitslohn.
Ach, guck mal.
Gibt ein neues...
Gibt ein neues Video. Hat er nicht...
Hab ich das letzte eigentlich schon geguckt? Was gibt es hier?
Frag doch nicht so blöd.
Softwareentwicklung ist viel zu teuer.
Ja, wenn man die
Projektekacke plant, sicherlich.
Ja, ja.
Bestimmt.
Hast du eigentlich einen
Staubsaugerroboter? Ja.
Hab ich. Jetzt musst du als nächstes
fragen, benutzt du den auch?
Und dann kann ich dir darauf antworten, nein,
mach ich nicht mehr. Den benutze
ich nicht mehr.
100.000 Euro
an einem Tag!
Ah, klar. Softwareentwicklung
ist viel zu teuer. Wie nennst du ihn?
Wie heißt sein Staubsaugerroboter?
Wie ich ihn nenne?
Ich nenne ihn gar nicht, weil ich ihn nicht benutze.
Es ist ein Roborock S5.
Aber ich benutze ihn nicht mehr.
Ich hab dem
keinen Namen gegeben oder sowas.
Mit dem Windows 11 Update
seid ihr schon durch? Ja.
Es hat coole neue
Funktionen und zwar wenn es nur
muss man sich, kann man sich ein bisschen
drüber streiten, was davon cool ist, aber
eine Sache und wenn es nur
das Endgruppieren
der Icons in der Taskleiste
ist. Das reicht,
das reicht mir eigentlich schon als Neuerung.
Ist es mehr Aufwand als manuell?
Es ist schwer
zu sagen.
Er fährt auf jeden Fall deutlich länger rum.
Du musst die Station ausleeren
laufend, was mich nervt.
Und mit dem Staubsauger an sich
bist du in 10 Minuten durch,
wenn man schnell ist.
Und
ich leere den Beutel,
keine Ahnung, im halben Jahr einmal oder so.
Vielleicht nicht ganz,
das ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Keine Ahnung, alle zwei Monate oder so.
Ja, ich staubsauge manuell.
Und wenn ich gar keinen Bock habe,
frage ich meine Mutter, ob sie nicht staubsaugen will.
Und staubsaugt die.
Irgendeinen Vorteil muss es ja auch haben.
Du musst dich auch fahren lassen,
wenn du nicht gerade zu Hause bist. Ja, habe ich ja gemacht.
Aber du musst ja trotzdem
den Staubcontainer und das
alles ausleeren.
Das war ja noch keiner mit Absaugstationen.
Ja, der kann auch wischen, habe ich aber nie verwendet.
Also,
die neuen Staubsauger-Roboter,
die jetzt so eine
Absaugstation haben,
das könnte man sich nochmal überlegen.
Das dumme bei denen ist,
dass es da vielmals nur richtig gut
mit offizieller App und China-Chinesen
Cloud gibt.
Da habe ich eigentlich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Also, ich musste meinen,
nach einmal spätestens zweimal leeren.
Der ist Wohnzimmer gefahren,
Schlafzimmer gefahren,
Flur, Bad gefahren.
Das war es.
Mehr konnte er nicht machen. Er konnte die Treppe nicht runter.
Und,
da war der eigentlich,
wenn nicht voll,
war er spätestens das nächste Mal voll.
Und in so einem Beutel
von einem Staubsauger,
von so einem manuellen Staubsauger,
passt halt auch richtig viel rein,
im Vergleich zu so einem Mini-Behälter.
Oh,
17 Minuten ist mir jetzt zu lang.
Okay, Leute.
Ich gucke mir jetzt noch ein bisschen
YouTube an, Twitch oder sonst was.
Und,
in so einer Dreiviertelstunde gehe ich dann
pennen. Morgen muss ich nicht
arbeiten. Montags habe ich frei.
Das heißt, ich bin wahrscheinlich
morgen Mittag oder so und morgen Abend nochmal ein bisschen
on. Und dann in der Woche
wieder ganz normal,
wenn es mir danach ist.
Also Streamingplan habe ich ja nicht.
In letzter Zeit war ich relativ viel on,
aber in den letzten Wochen wieder recht wenig.
Also sagen wir mal so, dieses Jahr insgesamt
recht viel, aber in den letzten Wochen wieder
recht wenig. So ist es immer so, wie es passt.
Hast du dich irgendwie besonders
auf den ersten Tag beim neuen Arbeitgeber
vorbereitet?
Stimmt, aber nichts
Großes. Ich glaube,
ich, also ich habe,
ich habe, doch, doch, habe ich.
Ich habe geguckt, dass ich alles Wichtige auf jeden Fall
gepackt habe, also von Ausweis bis
Führungszeugnis
und
Zeug, was ich hatte.
Klar, ich habe
geguckt, dass ich halbwegs ordentlich ausschaue
und
ja, auf so ein paar Default
Fragen, von denen ich dachte, dass sie eh
kommen, habe ich mir schon mal ein bisschen was überlegt.
Ja, aber ansonsten
mein Tiefgreifen
vorbereiten kannst du dich ja nicht. Du weißt ja nicht
genau, was, was, was geht.
Ja, okay, Leute, wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut. Bis denn.